[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre grande
mission parlementaire du mercredi on est
ensemble jusqu'à 17h et au programme de
cette émission un peu spécial toutes les
réactions aux annonces d'edouard
philippe qui abat ses cartes il a
dévoilé les détails tant attendu de la
réforme des retraites alors que la grève
se poursuit toutes les réactions le
décryptage analyse en plateau avec de
nombreux invités et au micro d'alexandre
poussard salle des conférences
et puis les retraites et le climat
social sont bien sûr au menu des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
alice bardot et présenta les fidèles au
poste dans l'hémicycle du sénat pour
vous faire vivre ce temps fort de la
semaine parlementaire est d'ailleurs
alice et bien edouard philippe va
répondre à beaucoup beaucoup de
questions cet après-midi et witam pas
moins de sept questions à ce sujet et ce
dès l'ouverture de la séance avec des
questions des présidents des groupes
politiques mais aussi de sénateurs de
tous bords politiques alors si on doit
évidemment pas s'attendre à de nouvelles
annonces de la part du premier ministre
qui s'est déjà exprimé longuement il est
à peine une heure ces questions
d'actualité vont être l'occasion d'avoir
les réactions à chaud des sénateurs
l'occasion aussi pour celui qu'on
appelle le monsieur retraites du
gouvernement
jean paul delevoye de prendre la parole
et ce sera donc dans l'hémicycle du
sénat
merci beaucoup alice on vous retrouve
donc dans une heure juste avant les
questions d'actu et le hashtag je vous
le rappelle pour réagir et commenter
cette émission c'est toujours kg
[Musique]
pendant tout une heure on va prendre le
temps de recueillir toutes les réactions
aux annonces du premier ministre et
d'analyser son plan il maintient à la
réforme universel annonce la fin des
régimes spéciaux et une mise en place
progressive première génération
concernée celle née en 1975 mais un
sujet déjà en train de crisper les
syndicats même les syndicats réformistes
comme la cfdt la mise en place d'un âge
déquilibre à 64 ans retour donc sur les
principales annonces du premier ministre
avec marion vigreux après sept jours de
grève c'est l'heure du grand oral pour
edouard philippe
une prise de parole qui commence par une
mise au point la question n'est pas de
savoir si le gouvernement va tenir
si certains syndicats vont gagner si
d'autres vont perdre
il n'y aura ni vainqueur ni vaincu
dès le départ le premier ministre
rappelle sa détermination totale à faire
disparaître les régimes spéciaux
la transition entre les 42 ancien régime
et le nouveau système est un défi
considérable et je comprends qu'il
puisse inquiéter le système universel
par points sera donc la norme et il sera
fixé sur les salaires et non sur
l'inflation
nous demanderons aux partenaires sociaux
de fixer sa valeur et son évolution sous
le contrôle du parlement
et parmi les concessions accordées pour
calmer la grogne sociale
il ya le maintien à 62 ans de l'âge
légal du départ à la retraite
néanmoins âges pivots à 64 ans sera
instaurée avec un système de bonus malus
autre évolution les générations
concernées par la réforme
exit la génération 1963 le système
s'appliquera pour la génération 1975
toute la partie de carrière effectuée
jusqu'à 2025 donnera lieu à une retraite
calculée sur les anciennes règles
seuls les années travaillées à partir de
2025 seront régies par le système
universel
la génération 2004 sera la première à
intégrer le système dès le 1er janvier
le gouvernement souhaite accélérer les
négociations et maintient le calendrier
de la réforme
le texte sera prêt à la fin de l'année
présenté en conseil des ministres le 22
janvier et discuté au parlement à la fin
du mois de février et on va revenir sur
toutes ces annonces faites par le
premier ministre edouard philippe
à midi autour de la réforme des
retraites avec quatre invités sur ce
plateau rené paul savary bonjourbonjour
sénateurs l ère de la marne vice
président de la commission des affaires
sociales et rapporteur retraite pour
cette même commission merci d'être avec
nous également sur ce plateau emmanuel
capus vous êtes sénateur les
indépendants république et territoires
du maine-et-loire vice président de la
commission des finances merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation également sur
ce plateau benoît test bonjour vous êtes
secrétaire nationale de la fsu on va
voir si et bien vous avez été satisfait
par les annonces du premier ministre et
enfin sur ce plateau eric chevet bonjour
je vous êtes vice président de la ces
pme à la confédération des petites et
moyennes entreprises vice présidente des
affaires sociales pour la ceppm vous
avez d'ailleurs assisté à ce disque ou
total arrive juste oui et bien voilà on
va pouvoir en discuter alors tout le
monde se disait eh bien qu'il y avait
beaucoup de flou bien sûr autour de
cette réforme depuis plusieurs jours
c'est ce qui est dénoncé
de tous côtés quand il ya un fouet note
au monde se dit qu'il ya un loup rené
paul savary est ce que aujourd'hui avec
les annonces edouard philippe
vous y voyez plus clair et encore avant
même un certain nombre de précisions il
ya une grosse on compte porter une
reprise du rapport de jean paul delevoye
d'ailleurs une confirmation de ce qui
avait été préalablement déjà indiqué
avec quelques modifications et la même
stratégie en fait
ou fait une réforme systémique mais en
même temps on prend quelques mesures par
métriques hp ou la revalorisation euros
des petites retraites à carrière
complète une mesure paramétrique
et puis on affiche une volonté de
supprimer les régimes spéciaux
effectivement mais on les maintient
quand même pendant au moins 18 ans
puisque ça va je sais la génération en
1975 qu'il est concerné après il ya un
certain nombre de choses tout à fait
importante qu'il faut voir c'est vrai
que la phase de transition il a une
phrase cruciale eux dans les jours qui
viennent
effectivement on va en parler d'ailleurs
d'abord un premier mot un benoît test
vous bien sûr l'impression générale et
puis on va analyser point par point les
différentes annonces du premier ministre
mais l'impression générale c'est quand
même le maintien du flou on a de nouveau
les éléments de langage mais qu'on
entend depuis 18 mois maintenant avec
jean paul delevoye et avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement qui nous disent système
plus lisible plus juste et c'est
confirmation en revanche ça c'est
peut-être une petite nouveauté et c'est
ce qui est un petit peu plus clair mais
c'est pas fait pour nous satisfaire
ces confirmations effectivement dû
paramétrique dès 2022 a priori voire
même un peu avant confirmation d'un âge
pivot qui avait été remis en cause un
moment par emmanuel macron les 64 ans
pivot et qui du coup rendent
complètement illusoire et bidons la
promesse selon laquelle la valeur du
point ne baissera pas peut pas dire en
même temps le poids ne baissera pas et
dire on aura un âge pivot qu'on fera
varier et on vous dira 64 ans combien il
vaut et peut-être que l'âge pivot pourra
reculer donc beaucoup de déception
beaucoup de flou maintenu les
transitions très honnêtement on n'a pas
compris grand chose à ce qui allait se
passer
d'accord emmanuel capus un mot tout
d'abord de réactions sur le discours du
premier ministre
une heure de discours avec pas mal
d'informations et ben match a été un
discours extrêmement clair on avait
justement reproché au gouvernement nous
dit-on claire vougny ben non justement
jusqu'à maintenant on reprochait le flou
maintenant on peut pas dire que
le premie ça a été extrêmement clair
extrêmement longs extrêmement charpenté
autour de plusieurs axes effectivement
plus de clarté plus de justice plus d'
équilibre aussi
moi j'ai trouvé ça je trouve je trouve
que c'est un exercice réussi
effectivement mairie de chevet vous qui
étiez dans l'assistance un clay avait
entendu le premier ministre à s'exprimer
on a beaucoup entendu et bien les
syndicats à la sortie de ce discours qui
était assez négatif vous quel a été
votre avis sur ce disque alors peut-être
deux remarques qui moment surprise
d'abord c'est l'accélération du
calendrier donc le premier ministre
répond effectivement à la préoccupation
du flou qui réagit t la société
française c'est vrai depuis ces derniers
temps donc une accélération du
calendrier puisque maintenant on parle
quand même d'une loi votée en février
je pense que là pour le coup ça va aller
très très vite compte tenu de l'ampleur
et de l'étendue de cette réforme je
pense que d'ailleurs on nous dit que on
renverra ça pour beaucoup à des
ordonnances et à dd créée donc il y aura
un gros gros travail de déminage il fut
m'exprimer ainsi sur ces ordonnances et
sursee décret parce que c'était ses
excuses chose de très très concret
ensuite deuxième remarque c'est le
renvoi de la patate chaude aux as
partenaires sociaux en fait un très
clairement je pense que c'est une
manoeuvre assez habile mais qui couvrent
pas forcément mais à quand la situation
ne s'est pas plaisant génère alors oui
c'est vrai mais nous on sait prendre nos
responsabilités quand les règles sont
claires quand les règles sont claires et
nous sommes nous de ce point de vue là
prêts à prendre nos responsabilités dès
lors que les règles seront claires et
que on aura bien préciser ce qui relève
de la responsabilité des partenaires
sociaux
et ce qui relève de la responsabilité de
l'état or là il ya peut-être encore des
choses à travailler
alors on va balayer ensemble un certain
nombre d'annoncés en fait pareil d'or
philippe ou de confirmation il y avait
des choses qui se murmurait déjà depuis
plusieurs jours tout d'abord est bien le
fait que l'instauration de la réforme se
fera de façon progressive première
génération concernée celle née en 1975
nous a expliqué edouard philippe
on les coûts tant pour les personnes qui
sont déjà dans la vie active
nous avons choisi de ne rien changer
pour celles qui sont aujourd'hui à moins
de 17 ans de leur retraite
c'est à dire pour le régime général les
personnes nées avant 1975 qui auront
plus de 50 ans en 2025
cela veut dire que toutes les personnes
qui se projette déjà dans leur retraite
qu'ils ont préparés qu'ils l'ont
planifié dans l'ancien système ne seront
pas concernés par le système universel
comme les retraités actuels eux mêmes
cela va sans dire mais faut toujours le
rappeler
ce n'est pas le salarié alors 75
génération 75 c'est pas la clause de
grand-père c'est la clause du grand
frère ou du grand canton oui c'est celle
à un petit peu mais effectivement on
peut comprendre qu'ils aient période de
transition mais ça on pouvait le prévoir
à l'avancé ce n'est pas la peine de
faire attendre le tout fait faire mettre
le pays à feu et à sang pour prendre ce
ce ce type de deux décisions maintenant
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que on prend en compte
effectivement les accords sociaux qui
ont pu être passés c'est à 17 ans de
l'âge prévisionnel de la retraite mais
il va y avoir une vraie distinction
entre ces générations 75,85 parce que
celui qui sera dans un régime salarié du
commun lui sera soumis la règle des 62
voire 64 ans ancien régime pour une
partie nouveau régime pour tous ceux qui
sont après 95 et entre 75 et 85
génération 1975 1985 celui qui est
cheminot qui prend sa retraite plus tôt
et bas et il sera toute façon sous
l'ancien régime
donc il ya une différence de traitement
à travers ces générations que ce n'est
pas la réalité ne s'est pas
l'universalité
donc attention à ça il faut des
précisions là dessus ensuite il faut des
précisions dans un certain nombre de
domaines les fonds de réserve on n'a pas
tout compris parce que les fonctions des
bandits des professions libérales et
vont payer la transition et les autres
c'était quand même la gouvernance comme
vous dites on a un partenariat nous on a
toujours soutenu la gouvernance
partenariale
ils savent prendre leurs responsabilités
sauf que vous êtes en liberté surveillée
très surveillé est-ce que l'âge pivot va
s'appliquer à l'ancien régime au nouveau
régime tout ça on sait pas encore donc
il ya un certain nombre de précisions
emmanuel capus vous entendez rené paul
savary on nous promet l'univers
l'équité mais déjà dans la transition eh
bien vous soulever un problème avec les
rats d'inéquité je crois pas qu'on
puisse la vierge inédite et je crois que
justement le premier s'est échiné à bien
démontrer le côté juste de cette réforme
je parle pas de la fin des régimes
spéciaux seulement moi ce que j'ai
renault tu es vraiment dans cette heure
de discours c'est le fait qu'il a déminé
l'ensemble des fausses informations
qu'ils pouvaient circuler
par exemple chez les femmes il avait
hier appelé pour les femmes ça sera
globalement très positif pour les
familles ce sera positif pour les toutes
petites retraites les retraites indigne
dans ce pays pour les agriculteurs les
artisans tous ceux qui ont une retraite
inférieure à 1000 euros pour les
séquelles clairement rappelé et puis
comme vous le dites le fait
qu'effectivement c'est raisonnable c'est
pas une fin brutale les régimes spéciaux
c'est une fin dans le temps c'est à dire
que ça touche évidemment pas fils a
aussi des mines et il a rappelé et il
l'a bien fait de le rappeler
les retraités ne sont pas concernés mais
il y avait des retraités qui étaient
inquiets pour leur retraite
non seulement les retraités sont pas
concernés mais effectivement c'est à
partir des gens qui sont à 18 ans de
leur retraite qui pourra y avoir un
effet dans le temps donc moi je trouve
que c'est effectivement extrêmement
justes et raisonnables
prenez pas ça va juste une réaction sur
la question des femmes notamment
est ce qu'elles sont vraiment les grands
gagnants de cette réforme et je ne suis
pas convaincu et un contenu des
nouvelles mesures faudra vérifier là
aussi ça demande des précisions parce
qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il ya quand même un certain
nombre de trimestre s'est converti en
pourcentage au troisième enfant 7 et 10%
de l'ensemble des pensions là ce sera
cinq fois 15% mais que de la pension de
la femme sauf avis contraire et donc la
politique en ce qui concerne les femmes
faut quand même être attentif
j'attire également l'attention c'est un
point positif les petits carrière 1000
euros pour carrière complète pour les
petites les petits salaires mais il n'y
a pas besoin d'une réforme systémique
pour faire mille euros si la vraie
réforme paramétrique également c'est une
décision c'est 2 milliards d'euros
ces 2 milliard d'euros qu'il faut mettre
sur la table un parce qu'il ya le coût
de toutes ces mesures qu'il faudra
estimer quand même mais ce qui est tout
à fait logique mais maintenant il va
falloir préciser tout cela si on veut
que la réforme soit comprise par les
français que l'on donne confiance aux
jeunes parce que je suis pas sûr que à
travers le dispositif actuel nos jeunes
retrouvent confiance
benoît de nos têtes d'ailleurs cet
objectif de 1000 euros il avait déjà été
inscrit dans une loi en 2003 et
finalement on n'y est pas du tout alors
qu on est en 2010 neuf donc pas parce
qu'on le promets qu'on est certain que
ça va arriver c'est ce que j'allais dire
c'est à dire effectivement les 1000
euros et l'objectif de relever valoriser
les petites pensions on le partage et en
donne acte au gouvernement de deux
d'avoir cette préoccupation mais les
1000 euros
dans quelles conditions la carrière
complète et qu'est ce que ça va vouloir
dire une carrière complète
tout ça c'est extrêmement floue et du
coup ce serait pas une avancée voire
même il y aurait pas grand chose si on
10000 euros en 2025 dont il semblerait
que ce soit avancé un petit peu je
voulais revenir aussi sur la question
des femmes c'est une question
intéressante parce que ses
caractéristiques de ce qui est dit
depuis le début c'est delevoye qui
affirme dans son rapport ce nouveau
système va favoriser les femmes
nous on a fait la démonstration ou en
tout cas on a dit des choses inverse on
a dit effectivement les femmes ont des
carrières plus arte plus haché et donc
si elles cotisent sur l'ensemble de leur
carrière
si l'ensemble des carrières et non plus
les meilleurs salaires entre en compte
alors ça risque de les défavoriser les
femmes ont moins d'indemnités dans la
fonction publique si on met tout dans
l'assiette
les femmes vont être défavorisés on n'a
pas de réponse et on a simplement de
nouveaux l'affirmation ça va favoriser
les femmes sans autre forme de procès et
sans autre démonstration est par
ailleurs moi je note que sur la
transition il ya quand même un côté
extrêmement contradictoires à vouloir à
dire que cette réforme est bonne et à la
reporter pour les générations qui vont
partir à la retraite tout de suite si on
a besoin de la reporter et si on a
besoin pour calmer les gens qui sont
dans la rue aujourd'hui est en grève de
dire ça ne vous concerne pas il ya quand
même un petit sujet là et un petit souci
pour défendre cette réforme est dans les
transitions dernière chose on nous dit
génération 75 je disais tout à l'heure
nous on n'a toujours pas compris ce qui
se passe pour par exemple quelqu'un qui
est né en 1970 à qui on va dire en 2025
vous avez vos droits acquis de pension
c'est juste pas 1500 euros vous avez 55
ans dans sept ans vous partez à la
retraite donc désormais j'imagine vous
cotisez en point ou peut-être pas ou
peut-être qu'il est prévu là encore des
transitions mais ces 1500 euros dont on
lui a affirmé en 2025 qu'ils étaient des
droits qui comment les valorise
est-ce qu'ils sont indexées sur
l'inflation sur les salaires est-ce
qu'on
donne de 1500 euros ce qu'on lui donne
1500 euros en 2030 de quand il part à la
retraite est ce qu'on lui converti ses
1500 directement en point qu'est ce que
ça veut dire qu'on fait conservation des
droits acquis ça c'est absolument pas
tranchée et du coup l'idée de transition
longue elle est là aussi à regarder de
près en tout cas on en est pas convaincu
et dernière chose il ya un âge pivot qui
est mis en place où il suit redevenir un
village pivot oui et tout d'abord une
réaction sur et bien cette génération 75
et puis c'est le caractère progressif à
ce que c'est pour vous quelques une
bonne chose quelque chose de rassurant à
eric chauvet alors nous nous l'essentiel
pour nous c'était qu'il n'y ait pas de
traitements différents entre l'immense
majorité des salariés de ce pays laisse
travailler les salariés du privé et les
indépendants et le reste la fonction
publique et les régimes spéciaux
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que le ce qui
est proposé est effectivement assez long
en termes de transition mais il ya
peut-être besoin d'avoir une longueur de
transition compte tenu de la complexité
de la tâche et que la différence tient
au fait aux caractéristiques
d'aujourd'hui en fait qu'il faut amortir
sur quelques années après après cette
période de 15 ans donc c'est vrai je
suis d'accord avec monsieur c'est à dire
qu' il ya encore beaucoup de flou sur la
façon dont ça va se sauva se bascule est
en fait un pot tous tous pour toutes les
générations entre 63 ans aujourd'hui et
c'est encore effectivement flou sur ce
sujet là mais on peut imaginer que
justement ces questions soient réglés
dans les discussions qui vont venir et
qui vont permettre d'aplanir tout ça
l'essentiel étant de fixer un cap pour
nous de fixer une régime sur lequel on
va aller tous ont tranquillement je
voulais ajouter un point sur la question
des femmes et sur la question des
petites des petites retraites
nous avons toujours nous plaidé lors de
la concertation auprès du haut
commissaire que ça n'était pas au
système de retraite de compenser
l'intégralité des des inégalités de la
vie ouais et donc c'est d'abord de la
vie qu'il faut évidemment prendre en
compte ces problématiques et non pas au
moment où on part à la retraite
à la retraite il y a effectivement des
choses qu'il faut corriger comme la
problématique des maternités pour les
femmes
il peut y avoir aussi de handicap
certain nombre de choses qui sont qui
sont à prendre
on compte effectivement mais c'est
d'abord une révolution dans la manière
d'aborder le travail est pour je termine
un petit point sur sur la question de la
retraite minimum des 85% du spip 1000
euros nous avons toujours nous plaider
aussi sur le fait qu'il fallait
reconnaître la valeur travail
or la différence qu'on va nous proposer
à terme 200 euros entre le minimum
contributif c'est à dire le minimum
retraite et les retraites
issu des minima sociaux c'est-à-dire en
fait exactement ces 900 920 euros au
terme du mandat je trouve que cette
différence de 10 % et lassina l'état et
donc du coup les mécanismes d'indexation
doivent permettre d'augmenter ctk tout à
fait je crois que c'est rapidement vers
années faisant effectivement c'est dans
la grille salariale qu'il faut réserve
régler ccc problème de différenciation
de salaires notamment entre mes femmes
actuellement le système corriger ces
inégalités y avait moins d'inégalités au
niveau des retraites de ses polymères
qu'au niveau des salaires donc il faudra
on avait bien examiner faudra trouver un
correctif 1 dans le nouveau système
parce que si on fait que l'application
du point qu'un système par définition
par contribution les inégalités sont
reproduite intégralement niveau des
retraites si on ne corrige pas ça donc
ça c'est des éléments importants de même
les réserves est ce que les airs et
réserve était là pour garantir le
financement des retraites c'était comme
ça que les régimes n'empruntait pas il
ne pouvait pas emprunter
maintenant il faut qu'elle serve
effectivement par rapport à ceux qui les
ont constitué à faire en sorte de
pouvoir avoir une transition qui se
complète mais il faut pas non plus beauf
et les réserves je dirais vulgairement
parce que sinon ce serait
contre-productif
un autre point qui a été marquant vous
avez commencé en parlais tout à l'heure
et bien c'est le fait que l'on ait parlé
d'un h pivot à 64 ans a quitté nantes on
parlait déjà depuis le rapport de le
voir c'est une affirmation qui risque de
mécontenter un certain déjà on va
écouter ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure
edouard philippe ans la seule solution
c'est de travailler un peu plus
longtemps et progressivement un peu plus
longtemps
comme c'est le cas partout en europe et
partout dans le monde
nous maintiendrons l'âge minimal de
départ à la retraite à 62 ans
c'est un principe de liberté auquel nous
voulons rester fidèles en laissant à
chacun la possibilité de partir à la
retraite à compter de 60 2 ans si son
parcours de vie
le lui permet où l'y invite nous allons
devoir inciter les français à travailler
plus longtemps
le gouvernement compte donc reprendre la
proposition du rapport du haut
commissaire qui consiste à instaurer au
dessus de l'âge légal un âge d équilibre
avec un système de bonus malus
le conseil d'orientation des retraites
nous dit qu'il faudrait fixer cet âge à
64 ans en 2025 pour atteindre
l'équilibré
cette date est d'ores et déjà un horizon
raisonnable pour la très grande majorité
des français et on va écouter la
réaction juste après ce discours de
laurent berger la cfdt qui étaient très
mécontents
bonjour pour la cfdt vous le savez il
avait une rouge dans cette danse est
cette réforme
c'était le fait de ne pas mélanger la
nécessité d'une réforme systémique pour
rendre le système plus juste que lisible
et la réforme paramétrique qui
demanderait aux travailleurs de
travailler plus longtemps
cette ligne rouge est franchie allait
clairement franchi et c'est pas parce
que on nous on nous montre un chemin qu
en août on aurait soi-disant
les manettes pour le choisir finalement
on sait qu' il y aura un âge déquilibre
à 64 ans fixe est donc d'ores et déjà
par cette réforme
deuxièmement concernant les mesures
sociales de de la réforme systémique en
tout cas de ce qui est présenté comme la
réponse systémique
il y a encore beaucoup d'insuffisances
notamment sur la question de la
pénibilité avec la réintégration des
quatre critères qui avaient été exclus
en 2017
donc il y a aussi des insuffisances sur
le volet social de cette réforme
concernant notamment le minimum
contributif avec un relèvement
insuffisant
je réunis cet après midi au bureau
national de la cfdt qui décidera des
actions de la cfdt dans les jours à
venir dans les jours et les semaines à
venir mais je crois que cette réforme et
a été lesté par un angle budgétaire
accrue et donc on va essayer de la
délester dans les semaines à venir je
vous remercie ligne rouge nous dit donc
laurent berger qu'en pense de la
sénatrice sophie taille et polluant sna
trice génération du val de marne à
l'état votre micro alexandrins plus tard
c'est à vous sophie calle polluants se
détache déquilibre cette retraite réel à
taux plein à 64 ans c'est une ligne
rouge franchi selon vous vous êtes
d'accord avec laurent berger mais
écoutez c'est une ligne rouge de plus
pour nous parce que nous étions déjà
extrêmement mobilisés contre contre
cette réforme et les principes qu'elle
met en oeuvre parce qu'elle va
fragiliser davantage les pensions et les
futurs retraités
mais là bien entendu ça va encore plus
loin parce que cela modifie non pas un
système à venir mais je dirais le
système actuel en repoussant encore en
fait l'âge du départ à la retraite
on est vraiment dans une période de
régression sociale souvenons nous il n'y
a pas si longtemps que ça on passait à
la retraite à 60 ans depuis entre green
iott et on nous parle quand même de
justice sociale je crois que les
français n'y croient pas donc pour vous
il n'y a pas de nécessité d'atteindre
l'équilibré financier du régime des
retraites fait l'objectif d' edouard
philippe
écoutez le régime financier tel qu'il
est mis enfin tel qu'il est mis en avant
c'est quand même basé sur un certain
nombre de décisions qui sont des
décisions d'austérité et notamment du
fait d'une grande baisse du nombre de
fonctionnaires
si on n'était pas sur un retrait du
service public comme ça on aurait
davantage de cotisations et à ce
moment-là l'equilibre du système ne
serait pas remis en cause dont c'est
tout un tas de décisions qui sont des
décisions d'austérité de la part de ce
gouvernement et qui finissent évidemment
par poser problème posé problème parce
que ça empêche le pays de repartir en
avant vers la croissance et poser
problème pour les services publics et
poser problème pour les retraites mais
finalement des mesures d'allongement de
la durée du travail pour équilibrer
davantage le régime la gauche aussi on a
prises c'est cette une
une mesure de responsabilité non non ce
n'est pas une mesure de responsabilité
parce que c'est ce n'est pas prendre en
compte la réalité sociale que les
personnes âgées vivent actuellement et
notamment
il ya une baisse de l'espérance de vie
une différence majeure de l'espérance de
vie des français en fonction de leur
travail s'ils sont ouvriers ou s'ils
sont cadres qui est de l'ordre de 6 ans
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé donc
s'attaquer à ces problèmes là ce serait
vraiment faire des justices delà des
mesures de justice sociale
très bien merci beaucoup se fait tailler
polluants pour votre réaction c'est 64
ans ils sont donc synonymes et bien deux
réformes budgétaires d'austérité nous
dit sophie taille et pau lyon emmanuel
capus en tout cas l'impact c'est que il
y a des syndicats qui n'était pas encore
dans la rue qui vont certainement y
aller notamment la cfdt
là c'est effectivement un mac du
caractère des joueurs philippe qui est
profondément honnête
il aurait pu par tactique politicienne
dire enfin s'en tenir à ce qu'il a dit
sur les soixante deux ans ça reste l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite et je
renvoie aux partenaires sociaux
négocient entre eux et ils verront verra
qui avait point d'équilibré
c'est parce qu'il dit profondément de
façon très honnête de façon très claire
il dit moi je crois qu'ils impriment
déquilibre et je crois que l'équipe est
à 64 ans on peut au moins mettre ça à
son actif cette honnêteté cette
transparence qu'il savait effectivement
on traite tous autour de cette table que
pour laurent berger ce serait une
première fois un problème aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les français sont à même de
le comprendre je le pense lire
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce que dit
ça fait sophie calle polluants la
moyenne d'âge el fad l'espérance de vie
elles augmentent drastiquement tous les
pays du monde et travaillent plus que
nous tout à fait européen il le problème
de la transition c'est quand vous régler
un problème vous entrez un autre c'est
la vraie difficulté passer effectivement
est dans un système par annuités d'un
système par annuités à un système par
points
et donc nous nous avons toujours dit une
espérance de vie supplémentaire faut
trouver le juste équilibre dans cette
espérance de vie entre le travail et la
retraite supplémentaire c'est pas
possible de faire autrement
donc c'est une mesure à la fois trahi
ses incontournables de l'adrar compte
par contre par contre il faut
accompagner des mesures de prise en
compte de la pénibilité et de l'emploi
des seniors peut pas d'un côté dire les
seniors bacchantes is over dig
on en veut plus dans les entreprises et
puis de l'autre côté il faut travailler
plus longtemps donc il faut trouver un
juste qu'il faut proposer des mesures
d'accompagnement clair net chat
pénibilité elles sont pas suffisamment
claires nettes et des mesures
d'accompagnement de la politique
familiale parce que le principe d'un
système de répartition
ce sont les enfants qui payent pour les
parents donc faut accompagner une
politique il fait bien plus dynamique
que celle qui est proposée me
semble-t-il
benoît un test sur les 64 ans c'est une
ligne rouge nous dit laurent berger et
pour vous ne sait ni plus une ligne
rouge ni moins que ce qui était proposé
dans le rapport delevoye ce qui avait
été dit après par emmanuel macron qu'on
pourrait calculer les décotes peut-être
différemment en utilisant les durées
d'assurance ou autres modalités nous on
a toujours dit que le système par points
il permettait justement cet ajustement
automatique quasiment de la valeur du
point à l'augmentation de l'espérance de
vie à la diminution des ressources qu'on
organise d'ailleurs sciemment c'est ce
que dit notre votre votre collègue
sénatrice alex les exonérations de
cotisations etc font qu on assèche le
budget de la sécurité sociale
malgré cela il n'y a pas besoin de faire
des mesures d'ici 2025 parce qu'on a vu
aussi tout le cinéma autour du rapport
du cor qui en réalité ne faisait que
dire qu'il y avait des besoins de
financement qui était extrêmement réduit
d'ici 2025 qui n'a pas un déficit
colossal d'ici 2025
et si on augmentait les ressources si on
augmentait le ressources on pourrait
améliorer le système actuel et quand il
va y avoir plus de retraités dans la
société future on pense nous qu'il faut
effectivement que la part des richesses
qui est consacrée aux retraités soient
plus importantes pas dans des
proportions démesurées mais augmenter la
part de 14 à quelques points de plus de
richesses nationales 14% aujourd'hui par
qu'on veut limiter l'augmenter un petit
peu plus ça serait nécessaire parce que
nous on parle de besoins de financement
pour le système de retraites et donc ça
va pas du tout dans le bon sens que de
d'augmenter les durées de diminuer le
montant global des pensions et on
continue à s'y opposer c'est pas plus
une ligne rouge que ce qu'ils avaient
déjà sur la table et je vais vous votre
sentiment sur cette voie 3,64 en épis
sur un mot tout de même sur la retraite
par points on se rappelle aussi qu'il y
avait eu ces mots de françois fillon
dont on a beaucoup parlé
ces derniers jours lors de la campagne
présidentielle il avait dit bon ce qui
est pratique avec la retraite par coince
aussi qu'on va pouvoir et bien baisser
le point plus facilement et pouvoir
baisser le montant des pensions de plus
facilement occultées c'est ce qu'on fait
un village à l'agirc-arrco quand même
les 16 millions de salariés du privé où
les monter a donc et pour une bonne
partie d'ailleurs d'entre eux c'est
l'essentiel de la retraite il faut quand
même le disque dur qui est gérée de
cette façon là partent eux par les
partenaires sociaux dans un cadre très
définis c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas le
droit de s'endetter et donc du coup
congères qu'on a su créer des réserves
complémentaire à hauteur de 70 milliards
qui nous permet effectivement de donner
de nous donner le temps s'il ya des
retournements cycliques nous donner le
temps pour prendre les mesures
d'adaptation nécessaires
donc je crois que lima imaginer qu'on
puisse le faire
pour l'ensemble de 16 millions à 30
millions c'est pas beaucoup et c'est
peut-être le double quand même mais je
pense que c'est tout à fait possible
nous nous sommes effectivement très
favorable au système en plein de mon
point de vue j'estime que c'est plus
visible que c'est plus clair pour la
totalité des français et que chaque
heure travaillée donne droit derrière à
a évidemment une rémunération pour la
retraite connu un retour pour la
retraite
donc ça s'est tenue c'est quelque chose
qui est qui nous ne nous choque pas du
tout je voulais simplement revenir sur
un point c'est que nous sommes bien au
cir halla halla halla ces pme favorable
au développement de l'emploi et c'est
clair ce sont les entreprises avec le
salarié qui créent les richesses et qui
permette derrière d'assurer les systèmes
de protection sociale y compris et
principalement la retraite ddd des
retraités aujourd'hui donc nous nous
sommes favorables effectivement ça n'est
pas en mettant des risques sur des
charges supplémentaires des impôts
supplémentaires et du déficit
supplémentaire que nous arriverons à
créer plus de richesse
compte tenu que nous sommes pas tout
seul au monde et que nous sommes dans un
monde ouvert
il faut faire très attention là dessus
si on veut financer des retraites plus
tard il faut laisser aux entreprises la
possibilité de créer de la valeur
ajoutée et bien ça sera le mot de la fin
de ce débat merci à tous les cas tu l'as
dit avoir participé merci rené paul
savary et merci benoît test remercie
emmanuel
merci beaucoup eric chevet en tout cas
et bien noter qu'il n'est pas question
de reculer d'un journée la réforme le
texte vous l'avez dit il est annoncé
pour janvier et la majorité fait bloc et
d'un philippe est en première ligne pour
défendre le projet du gouvernement
c'est le 6e on l'attendait depuis des
mois on connaît désormais le contenu de
la réforme des retraites maintenant une
autre bataille souffle pour le
gouvernement
celle de l'opinion il va falloir qu'elle
met les colères mais aussi rassurer les
français
je le dis aux français qui s'interroge
sur notre projet il n'y a pas d'agenda
caché
nous ne cherchons pas des petites
économies ici ou là nous ne voulons
léser personne mais au contraire
protéger davantage le pouvoir d'achat
des travailleurs et le pouvoir d'achat
des retraités
pour apaiser les français premier
ministre et est président de la
république veulent désormais faire de la
pédagogie
il compte sur le soutien de leurs
troupes et en coulisses les deux têtes
de l'exécutif s'activent pour motiver et
rassembler leurs équipes
edouard philippe multiplie les rendez
vous avec les députés de l'assemblée
hier il a petit déjeuner avec eux il les
a écoutés mais les a aussi motivé pour
être les vrp de la réforme sur le
terrain après les annonces ce soir il
compte de nouveau les retrouver cette
fois pour détailler avec eux la réforme
emmanuel macron lui aussi continue de
consulter hier soir il a réuni jusque
tard les ministres et cadres de la
république en marche
impliqué pour la réforme pour leur
donner la feuille de route et leur
mission est la même que celle des
députés défendre le projet auprès des
français comme l'a fait ce matin jean
baptiste djebbari de ce projet il a été
beaucoup critiqué il a été aussi
beaucoup manipuler notamment par les
oppositions politiques
en tout cas il ya beaucoup de
désinformation est en tout cas
maintenant il faut la clarté qui est
concerné comment calcule les retraites
et les éléments de rassurance pour que
les gens mais des pressions sur système
il est positif
il s'agit aussi de rassurer sur le cas
jean paul delevoye
il reste bien le monsieur retraites du
gouvernement
malgré ces mises en cause pour conflit
d'intérêt et pour avoir occupé un poste
qui lui rapportait 5000 euros
il peut continuer à partir à la re
continue et il le continue d'autant plus
qu'il jouit d'un crédit auprès des
partenaires sociaux dont nous avons
besoin pour faire réussir cette réforme
edouard philippe lui va continuer son
marathon pour la réforme des retraites
et s'adressera ce soir directement aux
français au 20 heures de tf1 et on va
continuer à analyser bien les annonces
d'edouard philippe et puis cette folle
journée du premier ministre avec quatre
invités sur ce plateau michel amiel
bonjour j sénateurs la république en
marge des bouches du rhône vice
président de la commission des affaires
sociales également avec nous rémi féraud
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sénateur socialiste de paris vous êtes
membre de la commission des finances
également avec nous léonidas
kalogeropoulos vous êtes vice-président
du mouvement patronal ethic et enfin
avec nous un jean françois amadieu vous
êtes sociologue professeur à université
paris 1 panthéon sorbonne et vous êtes
spécialiste des mouvements sociaux
première question pour vous est ce que
pour vous le discours du premier
ministre va pouvoir calmer la rue bon on
a eu un début de réponse avec il faut le
dire les syndicats qui ont tous réagi à
l'issue de ce discours et on peut taxer
plutôt non oui ce qui est le plus
frappant
certes on peut dire que c'est une
posture jeu de rôle mais malgré tout la
future et le secrétaire général de la
cfdt
été oui mais était manifestement
particulièrement en colère il était déjà
d'ailleurs avant l' annonce parce qu'il
le savait mais
je veux dire que le ton est très ferme
et j'ajoute que du côté des l'unsa même
chose
les syndicats de police je les entendais
aussi apparemment sont mécontents ce
qu'il faut simplement rappeler c'est que
c'est quand même très difficile de
réformer quand on a perdu toutes les
organisations syndicales réformistes
cfdt cftc cgc unsa
c'est compliqué quand vous avez les
réformes des transports et de la
fonction publique a opéré et calmer le
jeu a la ratp la sncf et évidemment ça
se complique donc on verra ce que décide
la cfdt dans son bureau national est ce
qu'elle appellera à la grève au niveau
national interprofessionnel c'est pas
certain de quelles initiatives pareilles
parler laurent berger dans sa position
il reste qu il risque d'être difficile
de ne pas rejoindre le mouvement il nous
semble-t-il mais chanel ça va être
mission difficile voire impossible sans
tous ces syndicats réformistes
on a bien entendu laurent berger
lorsqu'il dit qu'on a atteint les lignes
rouges et bien son insatisfaction
notamment autour de cette question et
bien de l'âge pivot les 64 ans la
dimension paramétrique de la réforme
oui le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
laurent berger était particulièrement
clair dans une réaction que honnêtement
j'en attendais un peu ils avaient
annoncé la couleur si je peux dire alors
tu pas forcément pessimiste
alors certes les représentations
syndicales sont essentiels mais il me
semble quand même que les gens peuvent
comprendre avec une espérance de vie qui
a augmenté considérablement depuis les
années 50 à l'est depuis l'après-guerre
qu'il soit nécessaire de travailler un
peu plus longtemps pour moi c'est le bon
sens
c'est le bon sens est-ce que ce bon ça
on se sera compris par tous et bien j'ai
envie de dire on va le voir dans les
jours qui viennent
rémi féraud vous votre avis autour de
ces annonces du premier ministre il ya
aussi la non ce que ce sera plutôt
progressif ya aussi les annonces sur les
mille euros pour les 85% du smic pour
ses retraités les plus modestes il ya
aussi des choses un verre à moitié plein
et puis ce verre à moitié vide avec les
64 on le fait majeur ça va être pour la
probable entrée dans le mouvement social
de la cfdt
je pensais que peut-être tout l'objectif
de cette journée d'aujourd'hui après un
mouvement social très important elle est
justement d'être d'empêcher ça et c'est
exactement le contraire qui s'est
produit
de manière très volontaire je dirais que
les deux annoncent que je retiens forte
d'edouard philippe aujourd'hui c'est un
une clause du grand-père qui devient
très jeune grand père un grand oncle on
n'est même pas oui grand frère
génération façon on est sur le
calendrier poirson pour les usages du
plastique les 1040 oui et encore c'est
que le début parce que fait ça pourrait
durer jusqu'en 2070 si j'ai bien compris
la transition l'autre c'est
l'instauration de l'âge pivot c'est à
dire le choix vraiment de cumuler ce
qu'on appelle le paramétrique avec le
systémique c'est à dire de faire une
réforme financière ça me rappelle
exactement de manière inversée ce qui
s'est passé au moment de la loi travail
en 2016 tir qu'à un moment il ya eu la
volonté de remettre la cfdt dans le jeu
à l'époque pour arriver à apaiser les
choses
et voilà c'est tout le contraire
léonidas kalogeropoulos je vais vous
donner la parole un instant mais honneur
aux dames on va rejoindre salle des
conférences
alexandre au plus tard qu'il se trouve
avec françoise gatel sénatrice us et
quelle est elle
son avis après les annonces du premier
ministre et oui françoise gatel est-ce
que vous avez été convaincu par les
annonces d'edouard philippe sur cette
réforme des retraites alors que les
syndicats ont été très déçus notamment
les syndicats réformistes comme la cfdt
alors je pense que chaque internet
beaucoup d'impatience les annonces du
premier ministre et souhaité qu'il y ait
de la clarté et des précisions je crois
qu'on a eu des réponses un certain
nombre d'interrogations des avancées il
faut le reconnaître il affirmé les
avancées à caractère social je pense
notamment aux gens qui ont des carrières
un peu fracturé je pense aux mères de
famille je pense aussi aux étudiants et
je pense surtout à l'enjeu de la
question à laquelle nous sommes tous
confrontés c'est la sécurisation d'un
système de retraite basé sur la
répartition donc les syndicats
aujourd'hui ne sont pas contents ils
manifestent leur mécontentement en même
temps je pense que personne ne
s'attendait à ce qu'ils applaudissent le
premier ministre qui sait ça relève mais
je crois qu'il faut que chacun d'entre
nous se plonge dans cette nécessité de
solidarité surtout de sécurisation de
retraite qu'il n'existait plus et
aujourd'hui comment peut-on quand on
défend la justice sociale accepter qu'un
agriculteur est un niveau de retraite
désastreux que des étudiants quand ils
ont un job d'été y cotisent mais n'ont
pas le droit à la retraite
et comme on a des régimes spéciaux qui
sont aussi alimenté par l'impôt moi je
trouve qu'on a une réforme qui renvoient
la responsabilité de chacun de nous mais
aussi des partenaires sociaux qui auront
à gérer le système
donc pour vous les partenaires sociaux
en tout cas les syndicats en appelant à
continuer la mobilisation ne sont pas
responsables non je ne dis pas qu'ils
sont pas responsables mais j'ai dit il
faut être attentif à ce que l'on fait il
y a dans ce pays une expression des
partenaires sociaux est un droit de
grève qu'il faut absolument respecter
c'est une nécessité moi je n'ai aucun
souci avec ça et en même temps il est
aussi une démocratie représentative
il ya un président de la république qui
a été élu sur un programme qui annonçait
de réforme des retraites il faut aussi
l'entendre et donc est ce qu'on peut
continuer à dialoguer ou pense-t-on que
de bloquer le pays et d'entravé aussi
l'action de gens qui n'ont pas la
capacité à 20 h
est-ce que cela va nous aider à sortir
d'une ornière que chacun doit
reconnaître parce que je pense que la
question de fond que chacun parte 1
c'est la pérennité du financement d'un
système de retraite qui va rester basé
sur un principe de répartition de
responsabilité d'universalité
d'ailleurs il faut assurer l'avenir
l'astag mans merci at-elle d'avoir
répondu à mes questions merci c'est la
pérennité de notre système de retraite
qui est en jeu nous dit françoise gatel
vous êtes d'accord
léonidas kalogeropoulos que je suis
d'abord très
occupé par un des points qui étaient
évoquées par la sénatrice elle ne pas
bloquer le pays parce que d'avoir depuis
des semaines maintenant se débat depuis
deux ans à venir
il devait forcément déboucher sur des
décisions qui ne pouvait pas être que
des députés décision tiède pour apaiser
tout le monde
or c'est un peu ce que semblaient
attendre un certain nombre
d'interlocuteurs eelv et finalement on
va on va tous rangés on va repousser à
dans 50 ans l'un la réforme on
s'occupera pas de paramètres ludo
finalement fera rien il ya un moment
donné ou dans notre pays la capacité à
réformer en se mettant autour d'une
table pour faire avancer collectivement
des sujets majeurs et sur ses avancées
pour moi c'est très important de
garantir une retraite à 1000 euros pour
notamment nos agriculteurs je crois que
ça nous choque collectivement que ce
type de deux priorités ne soient pas
prises en compte toute la problématique
des femmes d'autres éléments également
que tes mises en avant par le premier
ministre sur le fait de préserver les
réserves de d'acteurs indépendants on
pouvait pas non plus imaginer que toutes
les retraites complémentaires soient
siphonner je trouve qu'il ya des
messages qui sont extrêmement forts
j'ajoute d'ailleurs que s'il n'y avait
pas eu de mesures paramétrique c'est à
dire si on n'avait pas véritablement
répondu à cette préoccupation récente du
corps qui est de dire que l'équilibré
financier n'est pas garanti
si l'équipe financier l'épargnant tisser
les retraites qui sont pas garanties et
comment peut-on aborder
il réforme des retraites sans cochez
cette case là que la cfdt en effet une
ligne rouge c'est sa responsabilité et
je trouve que c'est une responsabilité
grave que cette ligne rouge soit une
manière de dire on mettra le pays à feu
et à sang
parce que l'on prend des décisions qui
sont des décisions nécessaires le corps
qui parle rappelons le d'un déficit en
2025 entre eux 8 milliards elle ville
7,2 milliards d'euros
bon ça reste d'ailleurs une grande marge
d'appréciation entre les deux c'est
comme ça mais ça fait dans sa sphère
déficit jean françois amadieu
vous l'avez dit c'est difficile de
pouvoir réformer si on n'a pas les
syndicats réformistes est-ce que c'est
pas aussi difficile de réformer quand on
a pas l'opinion publique parce qu'en
tout cas les derniers sondages si on
regarde parions que ce sondage de l'ifop
du 9 décembre il dit que 53% des
français soutiennent ou tient même temps
sympathie le mouvement et puis il ya
aussi 59% des français qui estiment que
le gouvernement qui jusque là n'avait
pas dévoilé détaillé salaires
on va voir ça va changer et plus
responsable des perturbations que les
grévistes votre sentiment latent en fait
si vous voulez depuis 95 toutes les
conflits qu'on a eue sur les retraites
était à peu près sauf le ratp sncf mais
tous les autres étaient toujours soutenu
entre 53 et 70 pour cent soixante par
exemple 70% en 2010 mais on peut
réformer exemple 2010 malgré une opinion
publique défavorable
malgré quelques grèves elles peuvent
être dur aussi mais à une condition
c'est qu'on n'a pas toutes les
organisations syndicales contre soi ou
bien scénario de 2007 on a dealé avec la
cgt une partie des organisations
syndicales ou même 2003 jean-pierre
raffarin quand on ne fait ni l'un ni
l'autre
c'est un scénario de type 95 et ça se
passe pas très bien parce que dans les
entreprises on le sait très bien
si vous trouvez beaucoup d'entreprises
qui peuvent se dispenser d'avoir avec
elles les organisations syndicales
réformistes qui font une majorité avec
lesquels on dialogue
enfin dans n'importe quelle entreprise
on ne peut pas agir de cette manière
personne ne le fait donc s'imaginer
qu'on peut y arriver
c'est juste impossible donc je sais très
surprenant je voudrais dire que c'est
une crise majeure pas c'est pas
simplement qu'on va avoir un conflit
dans les jours qui viennent qui va durer
on aurait pu l'éviter
c'est surtout que c'était la
confirmation qu'il y a un vrai problème
de place des partenaires sociaux depuis
deux ans ça avait commencé un peu avant
pour tout dire mais c'est très clair
parce que ce que dit laurent berger
c'est que on refait le coût de
l'assurance chômage c'est à dire nous
filent l'exécutif fixe les règles et dit
aux partenaires de toute façon si vous
ne vous mettez pas d'accord sur la
valeur du point où sur les 64 l'âge
pivot bonus malus ou sur l'assurance
chômage c'était pareil de toute façon on
interviendra derrière vous en faites pas
donc vous compter pour du beurre et
laurent berger était déjà furieux que ça
a été fait comme ça d'ailleurs avec le
patronat à l'époque je sais bien les a
continué remet le patronat était sur la
même ligne et sur le même et nous sommes
là ils sont
aujourd'hui j'ai pas aujourd'hui
pourquoi est ce que le patronat n'est
pas sur la minute lorsque nous avons eu
réalité arithmétique qui est
effectivement sur la question de l'âge
et je trouve franchement l'entendons
pouvait à tour un syndicat réformiste
d'avoir remis ça aussi je l'entendis la
garantie qu'on ne doit pas toucher à
l'âge alors le sujet de la g km élément
majeur
je trouve que ça pose aussi la question
de savoir si oui ou non ceux qui se
disent non juste on va repartir salle
des conférences car olivier du soft est
au micro d'alexandre poussard que dit le
secrétaire d'état
vous avez parlé jean françois amadieu de
crise majeure à l'instant olivet du soft
plus de deux ans de concertation sur
cette réforme des retraites avec les
partenaires sociaux
et au final le gouvernement va au bras
de fer avec notamment les syndicats
réformistes comme la cfdt
je crois qu'il a dit chante discussions
qui sont encore ouverts nous savons que
l'intervention du premier ministre
n'allait pas un tour résoudront discours
résout pas tout mais il apporte des
clarifications sont extrêmement fortes
sur le caractère universel du système
sur les modalités pratiques de mise en
oeuvre avec le report par rapport aux
préconisations à la génération 75 pour
le régime général mais ta volonté aussi
d'apporter des nouveaux droits comme un
minimum contributif pour toutes celles
et ceux qui ont cotisé pendant toute
leur carrière dès 2022 hauteur de 85% du
smic plutôt que de 75 % aujourd'hui
après il faut que nous puissions assurer
cet équilibre l'équilibré du système
c'est là que le premier ministre dit il
y a une méthode qui consiste à avoir un
âge équilibre avec un bonus et un malus
tout celui ci peut être progressif mais
qu'il ya aussi une discussion à voir
dans la gouvernance avec les partenaires
sociaux pour voir s'il ya d'autres
trajectoires qui permettent d'assurer
cet équilibre donc par exemple sur cette
date de 2000 27 pour 7h d'équilibré à 64
ans il est il et il est fixe il vous
pourrez bouger sur ce sur 7 initialement
l'objectif était d'avoir un équilibre en
au début du nouveau système parce qu'il
est plus logique d'entrer dans un
système en étant l équilibre qui entrait
dans un système en ayant déjà une dette
comme un boulet au pied
le premier ministre a ouvert cette porte
jusqu'en 2027 pour une entrée provisoire
progressif pardonnez moi ça n'est pas un
lapsus pour une entrée qui soit aussi
progressive par rapport à l'année de
naissance dans la mesure où il ya eu un
recul de manière à pouvoir aller moins
brutalement plus doucement et emporté le
maximum de monde avec nous au delà de
cela il y avait une bonne et 2025
une bascule de système il ya une année
2022 à partir de laquelle nous allons
mettre en place de nouveaux droits
notamment sur le minimum contributif ou
pour la revalorisation d'un certain
nombre de métiers comme les enseignants
alors une question sur les
fonctionnaires parce que vous êtes le
secrétaire d'état qui travaille beaucoup
sur sur les agents de la fonction
publique il ya un coup de pouce pour les
enseignants notamment aussi pour les
aides-soignants mais pour les autres
fonctionnaires ce sont les grands
perdants de cette réforme ce ne sont pas
les perdants les fonctionnaires pour une
raison très simple
jusqu'à présent les fonctionnaires
cotisent sur leur traitement indiciaire
et non pas sur leurs primes ou alors de
manière très marginale cette réforme
propose d'intégrer les primes dans
l'assiette de cotisation vous faire en
sorte que la retraite des fonctionnaires
leur pension soit calculé véritablement
sur la réalité de leurs revenus et pas
sur un revenu aux côtés des primes et en
ça c'est un vrai progrès c'est une
attente forte
nous avions dit deux choses qu'il
fallait veiller à ce qu'aucun
fonctionnaire ne soit perdue pour les
enseignants s'agit de revaloriser les
carrières et nous avions dit qu'il
fallait revaloriser la rémunération des
enseignants en même temps qu'en mettant
en oeuvre la réforme le premier ministre
a proposé que la revalorisation pour les
enseignants soient discutées début 2020
et qu'elle s'applique dès 2021 soit
quatre ans avant le début de la réforme
ce qui est aussi un geste significatif
pour les aides soignantes en particulier
nous savons que nous devons mieux tenir
compte de la pénibilité ce qui me
demandent la cfdt faire en sorte de
mieux prendre en compte le travail de
nuit à miner les règles sur le privé
parce qu'il a des différences entre 8
heures et 10 heures de nuit
et puis surtout nous proposons pour
celles qui le souhaiterait céder ceux
qui le souhaiteraient d'utiliser les
comptes et pas longtemps pour pouvoir
aménager les fins de carrière
travailler à temps partiel en étant
rémunéré plan puisque ce sont des
joueurs qui sont dues par l'employeur
mais de manière régulière pour
progressivement aller vers la retraite
dans de bonnes conditions en fin de
carrière très bien merci beaucoup et le
sien choc d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
rémi féraud votre réaction à ce que dit
le secrétaire d'état olivier dussopt
pile du bas il ya des nouveaux droits
pour les enseignants pour les aides
soignants les fonctionnaires vont y
gagner à cette réforme avec notamment
aussi de l'inclusion leurs primes dans
le calcul des retraites
je pense que sur les enseignants c'est
une plaisanterie tous les calculs
montrent que les enseignants perdrait
environ quatre ou cinq cents euros de
retraite
ça dépend combien on injecte dans le
système enfin pour ceux ci on peut
injecter dans le système si j'ai lu des
chiffres on est sur plusieurs milliards
d'euros certainement au delà 10
milliards 10 milliards d'euros
le gouvernement dans la carotte il ya
quelques mois le gouvernement neuf ce
serait l'idéal le gouvernement nina n'en
a ni les moyens ni l'intention en
réalité donc je pense que je pense qu'en
fait nous poser les bases de pour rendre
impossible cette réforme qui voit là m'a
l'air quand même bien mal partie bien
mal parti aujourd'hui y compris par le
coût de la réforme à court terme
michel amiel oui mais alors on vous
attaque du côté du coût de la réforme si
on veut que ce soit juste pour par
exemple les enseignants la femme être
beaucoup plus que les 400 millions
d'euros qu'on nous a annoncé vu ma
position je veux bien admettre que je
fais le service après vente et que cela
n'est pas saine pour envoyer jeu
j'assume et j'assure jeu pas si
pessimiste que ça je vous rejoins aime
bien sûr la réaction très vive de
laurent berger et la probable entrée de
la cfdt dans la danse ne va pas
faciliter la vie je pense que là il ya
quand même une marge qui me paraît très
importante de négociation c'est presque
en tant que médecin je dis ça c'est la
question de la pénibilité
la raison de la pénibilité a quand même
été largement
abordé par le premier ministre et je
pense à des professions qui seront
souffrance et ça il faut pas se raconter
des histoires c'est les professions de
santé à l'hôpital
a fortiori lorsqu'elles font les nuits
je pense aux infirmières je pense
peut-être encore plus aux aides
soignantes et le travail de nuit en
général et cette notion de pénibilité
bien conduite pourrait amener à une
négociation intéressante
maintenant nous rêvons pas on savait
bien que l'âge allait être le point de
blocage
alors fallait-il être démagogique et
renvoyer sa aux calendes grecques
moi je ne le pense pas toute façon dans
la plupart des virages assez téméraire
les 64 ans quand même écouter on dit
comparaison n'est pas raison certes
enfin regarder quand même les grands
pays européens l'allemagne regardait la
scandinavie l'âge légale a été repoussé
il me semble quand même que 64 ans comme
âge à pivot était quelques hommages
pivot pardon était quelque chose de
raisonnable
bon je sais bien que c'est le point
d'achoppement
mais je sais bien aussi que rocard avait
dit que il y avait rien de mieux je
certifie qu une réforme les retraites
pour casser un gouvernement
on va voir je pense qu'il fallait ce
courage et non pas cet émérite recart
qui d'ailleurs a été citée par ailleurs
philippe dans son discours mais je
trouve quand même que dans cette réforme
qui est annoncé dans ces grandes rock
autour mais qui va être débattu
maintenant le parlement va voir sa place
pour apporter des ajustements mais la
quantité de paramètres qui ont été pris
en compte on a beaucoup critiqué nous
mêmes
le fait que le projet n'était pas sur la
table depuis tournoi comme en débattait
mais la complexité dans laquelle on est
arrivé à la fois entre les différents
métiers les éléments de pénibilité les
équilibres tout le monde qui est cité
vous pour parler professions de santé la
fonction publique les agriculteurs les
indépendants enfin le nombre de
paramètres pour que l'ensemble de cette
réforme soit une réforme à la fois de
justice mais qui également on en
garantissent
l' équilibre majeur je trouve que c'est
un discours de responsabilité qui est
appelé alors maintenant j'entends ce qui
se passe avec des organisations
syndicales dont je ne serai pas de
déplorer l'incapacité à se mettre autour
d'une table pour faire avancer
collectivement notre pays il n'y a pas
que la rue pour faire avancer le
dialogue social
loin s'en faut mais il y a aussi le fait
de passer outre et de parler aux
français et je trouve que le discours du
premier ministre est un discours
responsabilisant vis-à-vis de la
collectivité nationale et des citoyens
il y avait deux voilà à peu près ce que
nous allons faire comme progrès ensemble
en apportant des ajustements dans la
durée en plus c'est pas du jour au
lendemain pour que tout ça tienne la
route financièrement je trouve que c'est
un vrai progrès le premier ministre que
l'on voit d'ailleurs arrivé à quelques
minutes du début de la séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement on
a également vu arriver le président du
sénat gérard larcher qui va présider
cette science très largement consacrée
aux retraites de très nombreuses
questions prévues sur ce sujet jean
françois amadieu
non pourquoi mon pour conclure ce débat
autour d'un mot la façon dont
s'organiser quand même la communication
du gouvernement sur cette réforme
non ça va aboutir eh bien peut-être
aussi elle va recréer l'unité syndicale
vous disiez à quelques jours est bien
l'un des enjeux ça sera peut-être de
voir où sera l'unité syndicale la salle
aura peut-être créé avec avec ce
discourt
oui c'était c'est honteux c'est très
étonnant parce que effectivement
plusieurs organisations syndicales
réformistes avait fait savoir avant
pense à l'unsa surtout et la cfdt
qu'elle voulait bien elle aurait aimé
sortir avant évidemment dès que vous
attendez
plus on attend plus aucun conflit
comment ça a été le cas la ratp sncf
plus on rend difficile déjà la sortie
les organisations syndicales qui ont
besoin davantage pour sortir pour
l'expliquer à la base et de plus il faut
rappeler que tout se joue sur la ratp la
sncf ça reste vrai encore aujourd'hui en
france tous nos conflits se sont joués
sur ceux sur cet élément là il est
central
surtout en plein hiver j'ajoute que la
cfdt est influente aussi dans les
transports mais donc la cfdt l'unsa et
surtout l'unsa c'est la clé si vous ne
les avez pas eu en particulier la ratp
c'est quand même difficile de s'en
sortir alors j'entends que là le premier
ministre a décidé de botter en touche et
de renvoyer aux entreprises de transport
ça c'est la stratégie de type sarkozy
2007 vous renvoyer aux entreprises de
transport le soin de trouver un deal
c'est possible c'est pas assez c'est
assez malin parce qu'on va alors tout le
monde s'est aperçu qu'il avait rien
annoncé donc on renvoie donc moyennant
un conflit qui peut durer un petit peu
malheureusement là la porte de sortie
est possible ou tout simplement il
suffira de faire une pause du grand père
je résume à peu près où vous lâcher
encore beaucoup à la ratp sncf donc pour
arriver à vous en sortir c'est ce qu'on
avait fait en 2007 va beaucoup entendre
edouard philippe
il va répondre à plusieurs questions
voici entrons à la voix de jean-paul
delevoye une question politique sur jean
paul delevoye est il encore l'homme de
la situation après bien l es deux
événements qu'il y a eu lundi et mardi
il a dû démissionner d'un poste
d'administrateur dans un institut de
formation de l'assurance et hier d'un
feuilleton dans lesquelles il était
encore rémunéré absolument pas cette
rémunération dans le cadre d'un think
tank est elle conforme à l'article 23 de
la constitution
c'est peu probable sa demande à être
éclaircies et toutes les conclusions
politiques devront n'est tiré et
rapidement vous demander sa démission
jeckyll qu'il faut vérifier si les
conditions sont réunies ou pas un mot
michel amiel justement sur jean paul
delevoye est ce que c'est compliqué
qu'il incarne cette réforme en ce moment
aujourd'hui avec ces deux années il a
mené cette réforme de avec brio alors
peut-être que la communication qui
arrive aujourd'hui avec le discours du
premier ministre est un petit peu
tardive mais je suis prêt à le
reconnaître mais la méthodologie
utilisé par jean paul delevoye à mon
sens a été la bonne moi j'ai juste un
mot qui m'importe c'est pour tous les
commerçants pour tous les artisans pour
toutes les entreprises pour tous les
salariés qui ont du mal à venir dans nos
entreprises et travailler c'est une
situation économique épouvantable
certain point on doit réfléchir à la
retraite de demain mais la situation
économique
après une année de gilet jaune pour un
très grand nombre d'entreprises est
aujourd'hui absolument au coeur de nos
préoccupations patronales et je pense
que ce devrait être aussi au coeur des
préoccupations gouvernementales et
syndicales c'est un point essentiel on
peut pas bloquer le pays plus longtemps
oui cela alors que le mouvement
s'annonce certainement encore assez long
merci beaucoup à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à cette discussion
merci michel anel merci jean françois
amadieu rémi féraud et léonidas
kalogeropoulos est tout de suite et bien
on va partir salle des conférences
rejoindre alexandre poussard alexandre
vous êtes avec le sénateur communiste de
seine-saint-denis
fabien gay toujours pour parler de cette
question de la réforme des retraites
bien sûr oui fabien gay le premier ténor
philippe a dit que cette réforme des
retraites n'était pas une bataille c'est
la réforme du consensus
vous y avez cru non ce n'est pas une
bataille la raison c'est une provocation
faite au mouvement social et aux deux
millions et demi de personnes qui ont
défilé dans les rues les deux derniers
jours de grandes manifestations
c'est la gare social qui est déclaré
c'est la précarité de la naissance à la
mort tout ceci est inadmissible 64 ans
l'âge pivot la fin des régimes spéciaux
sans concertation le leur que nous
pourrions avoir une retraite de 1000
euros quand aujourd'hui par exemple à
votre île très agricole touche en
moyenne entre 350 et 700 euros
donc en fait c'est la sécurité universel
pour toutes et tous
c'est une mauvaise réforme est
aujourd'hui il n'y a que le retrait qui
est possible de cette réforme
donc pour vous il n'ya pas quand même
des mesures sociales dans cette réforme
sur les petites retraites notamment
mais quelle
mesures sociales 6 femmes sur les femmes
mais si vous voulez augmenter les
petites retraites il faut d'abord
augmenter les salaires parce que c'est
ça qui fait les cotisations sociales qui
rentrent dans les caisses de la sécurité
sociale et qui permettent ensuite
d'avoir une bonne retraite
il faut augmenter les salaires pour
avoir une meilleure retraite mais
personne ne croit que lorsque
aujourd'hui vous êtes pour la fonction
publique
calculé sur six mois sur les six
derniers mois ou dans la fonction privée
les 25 meilleures années que lorsqu'on
va calculer sur l'écart avant tout les
43 annuités c'est à dire l'ensemble
total de votre carrière qui va
comprendre les cdd les périodes de
chômage les périodes de stages pour les
femmes les périodes h et que tout ceci
va faire augmenter leur pension de
retraite personne ne croit ça est en
réalité ce qui se passe ce n'est pas une
simple réforme
le premier ministre vient aujourd'hui de
déchirer le contrat social de en france
qui lie la nation avait le peuple
français
très bien merci beaucoup pour merci aux
éditions fabien gay et on va tout de
suite allé dans l'hémicycle de ces du
sénat retrouver alice bardot alice quel
est le programme de ces questions
d'actualité il est vraiment centré sur
cette réforme des retraites et oui
alexandre l'aura bien compris le sujet
du jour seule la réforme des retraites
qui sera évidemment au coeur de ces
questions d'actualité avec maman de
cette question des sénateurs dès
l'ouverture de la séance alors j'en ai
chargés donc pour le premier ministre et
qui après avoir dévoilé le contenu de sa
réforme ce midi va faire face aux
réactions à chaud des sénateurs et plus
particulièrement à celle des présidents
des groupes socialistes communistes rdse
et les indépendants cette séance de
questions d'actualité sera aussi
l'occasion pour le monsieur retraites du
gouvernement jean paul delevoye de
prendre la parole pour répondre aux
sénateurs qu'ils interpelleront la
plupart des échanges s'annoncent tendues
puisque edouard philippe a notamment
confirmé la pluie la mise en place d'un
âge pivot à 64 ans côté syndicats la
cfdt a signalé qu'une ligne rouge avait
été franchi philippe martinez de la cgt
estime lui que le gouvernent
je cite se moque du monde la cgt
cheminots a appelé à renforcer la grève
l'unsa à la prolonger une grève qui en
est je le rappelle à son septième jour
et qui paralysent une bonne partie des
réseaux sncf et ratp et c'est d'ailleurs
précisément à ce sujet que claude
malhuret président du groupe
les indépendants posera une question au
premier ministre donc à l'évidence les
premières réactions après les annonces
d'edouard philippe laisse penser que le
climat social va se détériorer encore
plus ce qui ne l'est actuellement et les
échanges avec les sénateurs pourraient
bien le confirmer hier une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation a rassemblé
plusieurs milliers de manifestants
la cloche a sonné tout de suite les
questions au gouvernement
[Musique]
y at il des observations je n'en vois
point il est donc adoptée sous les
réserves d'usagé monsieur premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues l'ordre du
jour appelle les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmis sur public
sénat et sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif au temps et au
respect des uns et des autres la parole
est à notre collègue président jean
claude requier pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen monsieur le président vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président hommes ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
notre système de retraite par
répartition est un grande acquis social
conçu évolué après la libération par les
concepteurs le système de protection
sociale il constitue un pan essentiel de
notre pacte social fondé sur la
solidarité entre tous quelle que soit la
catégorie professionnelle ou la
génération c as juste titre que nos
compagnons compatriotes qui sont très
attachés
pourtant on ne peut ignorer les
changements profonds qui touchent notre
pays
vieillissement de la population
diminution du ratio actifs retraités
déficit budgétaire difficilement
soutenable ne rien changer en sort et
irresponsable alors que l'incertitude
mine notre cohésion nationale
nos concitoyens de saint imier et qui
attendent aujourd'hui de l'équité de la
quartier de la confiance afin de se
projeter dans l'avenir avec plus
d'optimisme
mon groupe est particulièrement attentif
à ce que cette réforme ne sont pas
uniquement par les tricks et de court
terme comme l'a appelée de nos voeux au
fil des plfss
cette réforme se doit non seulement
d'intégrer les projections
démographiques de long terme mais aussi
les transformations des modes de vie
découlant d'un logement de serre de vie
non les seules considérations
budgétaires ne constitue pas un dogme
indépassable nous combattions aspire à
vivre pleinement une retraite en bonne
santé après une vie d'efforts nous avons
lancé ce matin en train de mesures
fondées sur les principes d'un système
ce goût-là universel tenant davantage
compte des pénibilités des disparités de
carrière plus favorables aux femmes et
dont l'entrée en vigueur se ferait
progressivement une rue en suisse et en
particulier que le parlement soit
associé à la définition de la valeur du
point
il appartient désormais aux partenaires
sociaux de débattre ce projet dans le
cadre de dialogue social apaisé
pour l'heure les français sont très
attentifs et ils ont raison
comment comptez-vous assuré monsieur le
premier ministre qu'aucune catégorie
professionnelle ne soit perdante
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre
chez le premier ministre avait la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président hockey vous avez raison c'est
une réforme d'ampleur que nous voulons
mettre en oeuvre peut-être d'ailleurs
serait-il plus juste de parler de
refondation du système des retraites aux
fondations car ce que nous souhaitons
c'est substituer à ces quarante deux
régimes existants
un seul régime qui permettrait que
chaque euro cotisé par n'importe quel
française ou français quel que soit son
métier quel que soit son statut quel que
soit son âge puisse produire le même
effet et ouvrir les mêmes droits ce que
nous voulons en font c'est que au lieu
d'organiser la solidarité nationale par
statut ou par profession nous puissions
organiser sur l'ensemble de la nation
ce qui ne me semble pas une mauvaise
idée s'agissant de la solidarité
nationale et ce qui vous le savez
monsieur le président est une forme de
retour aux sources du projet initial de
création d'un système de retraite
on se souvient que enfin on se souvient
je ne m'en souviens pas mais je les lui
que les ordonnances de 1945 notamment
les ordonnances par audi avait pour
objectif la création in fine et d'un
système universel ce système universel
nous pensons qu'il est utile et même
indispensable de le créer aujourd'hui je
sais donc effectivement une refondation
d'ensemble que nous proposons nous avons
indiqué dès le début que notre objectif
ce n'était pas ça et là de faire telle
ou telle petites économies
c'était de dire la vérité aux français
compte tenu des transformations du monde
professionnel compte tenu du caractère h
et des carrières professionnelles compte
tenu des changements d'activité
professionnelle de nos concitoyens du
nombre de polypensionnés de la
complexité actuelle des systèmes de la
perte de droits que chacun subie
lorsqu'il change trop souvent de système
de retraite il nous apparaissait plus
adapté au temps qui viennent
de créer ce système par points par
répartition est véritablement universel
et nous avons dit très tôt très tôt que
la france n'était pas aux faux soumis à
des conditions démographiques
radicalement différente de l'allemagne
de la belgique du royaume uni bref de
toutes les grandes démocraties
occidentales et européennes lesquelles
ont tout tirer les conséquences des
évolutions démographiques en disant que
la seule façon de préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des pensionnés et le pouvoir
d'achat des actifs s'était
progressivement progressivement de
travailler tous un peu plus longtemps il
faut évidemment le faire de façon la
moins brutale possible le faire en
respectant les choix de vie de nos
concitoyens
les prévisions les orientations qu'ils
ont pu revenir dans leur vie
professionnelle dans leur vie familiale
même si j'ose dire mais qu' il fallait
le dire clairement c'est ce que nous
avons fait c'est ce que j'ai fait tout à
l'heure au conseil économique social et
environnemental en présentant un projet
de réforme qui j'en ai bien conscience
est complexe et que je ne peux pas en 2
minutes vous présenter ici j'ai déjà
dépassé largement et le président
larcher nous invite à respecter le temps
il a bien raison mais qui sera débattue
cher monsieur le premier vous avez de la
tva un peu genre je ne propose pas de
mode et est donc monsieur le président
au pied ce projet que nous avons mis sur
la table ce qui va donner lieu à des
discussions avec les organisations
syndicales j'ai bien noté qu'un certain
nombre était totalement opposée au
principe d'un système universel
j'ai bien noté aussi qu'un certain
nombre d'autres n'étaient pas opposés au
principe d'un système universel mais ne
voulait pas dire peut-être assumer que
en effet l' équilibre global du système
pour les années qui viennent reposait
sur le fait que chacun progressivement
aller travailler un peu plus
bon eh bien nous allons discuter ma
porte est ouverte ma main est tendue et
vous aurez remarqué que dans le projet
que nous avons proposé après les travaux
du haut commissaire il y a beaucoup
d'avancé ce qui montre que notre
objectif c'est de travailler avec les
partenaires sociaux bien entendu et puis
le moment venu avec l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat car ce débat sera
bien
du discuté à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat et j'ai même indiqué que je
souhaitais que ces discussions aient
lieu rapidement parce que je pense que
ce sujet passionne inquiète parfois les
français et qu'il faut donc le traité au
parlement jour vinci merci monsieur le
premier ministre la parole à madame la
présidente eliane assassi pour le groupe
communiste et citoyen l'écologiste
monsieur le premier ministre ce midi
donc vous avez franchi la ligne rouge
vous êtes hors jeu et vos annonces vont
continuer à faire coaguler toutes les
colères avec votre projet de casse des
retraites les français vous travailler
plus longtemps jusqu'à 64 ans et
toucheront moins de retraite alors que
les salariés du secteur privé comme du
secteur public et les jeunes sont
massivement mobilisés depuis jeudi
dernier vous maintenez votre projet
funes d'instauration d'un système de
retraite par points soumis aux aléas
économiques et financiers monsieur le
premier ministre effectivement vous
n'avez pas fait d'annoncé magique mais
vous vous êtes lancé dans un excellent
numéro de bonneteau dont personne n'est
dupe
malgré l'illusion de la concertation
sociale
la majorité de la population a bien
compris les dangers de votre projet de
réforme
malgré vos belles promesses qu'il y aura
ni vainqueur ni vaincu
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir se frotter les
mains ce sont les marchés financiers à
l'instar de ses financiers quatre soeurs
reçu par le président de la république
les blacks troc qui vont attirer les
salariés qui le pourront vers les
retraites par capitalisation les lignes
et maîtrise de votre réforme n'ont pas
bougé d'un iota
il s'agit toujours de mettre fin aux
régimes spéciaux de retraite existants
qui contrairement à vos mensonges sont
tous solidaires du régime général
il s'agit toujours d'un système de
retraite par points dont la valeur
servira de variable d'ajustement à vos
politiques d'austérité avec à la clé une
belle général des pensions et permettez
moi de rappeler ici que ce que la loi
fait un jour une autre loi peut le
défaire demain
vous confirmez aussi que les salariés
travailleront plus longtemps en fixant
le fameux âge pivot je les dis à 64
monsieur mini de points aussi attiré mon
attention votre volonté de diviser pour
mieux régner
en opposant les générations et ensuite
j'ai quand même bien noté que vous ne
touchez pas au capital l'argent-roi que
vous défendez des kings avec le
président on arrête ubik alors ce midi
hormis le medef n'avait convaincu
personne
à l'instar de beaucoup d'organisations
syndicales monsieur le premier ministre
vous demandons le retrait de votre
projet de réforme pour vous répondre
monsieur le premier ministre les
sénateurs madame la présidente
nous ne sommes pas d'accord et personne
ici on est surpris ni vous ni moi ni
personne
vous dites vous dit à juste titre ce qui
est vrai dans une démocratie ce qu'une
loi fait une loi peut le défaire vous
avez parfaitement raison mais je pense
madame la présidente que vous
reconnaîtrez qu'une bonne façon compte
tenu de cette évidence démocratique de
procéder ces 200 kg au moment des
élections sur ce qu'on fera c'est ce que
le président de la république a fait
s'agissant du régime universel de
retraite
c'est ce que la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale a fait en s'engageant au
moment des élections législatives sur le
système universel de leur retraite et
permettez moi de dire madame la
présidente qu'avec le respect que vous
et moi avons évidemment pour la
démocratie le fait qu'un gouvernement
met en oeuvre une promesse
présidentielle ne devrait pas ne devrait
pas me semble-t-il suscité de la
surprise ou même ou même de ce point de
vue là de l'interrogation première chose
donc il ya une légitimité politique
deuxième chose on peut sans doute ne pas
être d'accord sur les mesures mais il ya
une chose une chose qui me paraît
évidente c'est que aucune loi fait ou
défait tu ne changeras d'une certaine
façon la réalité de nos systèmes de
retraites et la réalité de notre système
de retraite madame la sénatrice est la
suivante lorsque nous avons conçu ces
systèmes de retraites il y avait quatre
actifs pour un retraité
aujourd'hui il y a
1,7 actifs pour un retraité cette
mécanique elle est inexorable inexorable
à long terme elle est inexorable tous
les autres pays du monde l'ont compris
l'on assume et en ont tiré les
conséquences et on fait en sorte que
pour préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
ce que nous voulons faire pour préserver
le pouvoir d'achat des actifs
ce que nous voulons faire le l'élément
déquilibre ne soit pas la valeur du
point mais c'est vrai la capacité
qu'auront nos concitoyens
progressivement à travailler un peu plus
et ça madame la présidente
ça ne changera pas autrement dit ne pas
régler ces sujets c'est s'exposer un
jour dans six mois dans deux ans dans
dix ans à une vérité cruelle la perte de
pouvoir d'achat massive des retraités la
perte de pouvoir d'achat massive des
actifs mais c'est ce qui se passerait
madame la présidente si nous ne faisons
rien c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
faisons un régime universel un régime
universel dans lequel au fond les
françaises et les français ont les mêmes
droits
c'est madame madame la présidente
les mêmes droits les mêmes droits quelle
que soit l'activité professionnelle les
mêmes droits les mêmes devoirs
m'enfin ça devrait vous parlez madame la
présidente les mêmes droits et les mêmes
devoirs ses seins dans une démocratie
est dans une république
c'est même la promesse initiale la
promesse initiale du régime des
retraites mais vous le savez
parfaitement
c'était ça elle était portée par votre
camp à l'époque par votre parti et
peut-être même qu'on n'aurait pas réussi
à créer ces régimes de retraite s'il n'y
avait pas eu cette promesse initiale et
vous le savez parfaitement et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui certains
abandonnent pour préserver peut-être des
situations acquises peut-être des
intérêts et bien moi je trouve ça
regrettable
je préfère construire un système
universel clairement conformément aux
engagements qui ont été pris avec un
dialogue avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales et dans la
clarté
je vous remercie
la parole est au président patrick
kanner pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain monsieur le président
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues monsieur le premier ministre
j'espère que vous allez bien
sûrement mieux que les 1 million quatre
français qui vont tomber dans la trappe
à pauvreté de votre nouveau système
d'assurance-chômage sûrement mieux que
les salariés au smic qui n'auront pas de
coup de pouce en janvier sûrement mieux
que les allocataires de l'apl qui vont
payer cash
votre réforme en 2020 nous y reviendront
sûrement mieux que le revenu de nos
agriculteurs qui attendent en vain les
résultats de la loi et galim sûrement
mieux que nos étudiants qui ont perdu 35
millions d'euros de crédits dans le plfr
2010 9 sûrement mieux que nous aide
soignant urgentistes enseignants
retraités qui ne sont pas dupes
quand il voit la progression exorbitante
des rémunérations des patrons du cac 40
et les dividendes de 50 milliards
d'euros dont vous avez alléger la
fiscalité ce ruisseau lmnp là celui de
l'argent roi
il existe bien c'est vous et vous seul
monsieur près ministre qui en est
responsable
dans un contexte délétère et anxiogène
terreau de la poussée de l'extrême
droite dans notre pays vous avez franchi
de nouvelles lignes rouges avec vos
annonces de ce midi
six lignes rouges se nomme âges pivots à
64 ans prise en compte résiduelle de la
pénibilité
c'est une réforme universel certes mais
injuste car avant tout fondée sur un
angle budgétaire et non sur des
principes de solidarité et d'équité
monsieur le premier ministre en
n'écoutant pas les français pas les
corps intermédiaires
n'êtes vous pas en train de briser notre
contrat social fondements de notre pacte
républicain
pour vous répondre à la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président caennais
rssi je vous écoute
au fond ce que je comprends c'est que
vous m'indiquer que depuis que nous
sommes aux affaires
tout va plus mal et c'est un point de
vue et je le respecte sa conséquence
mécanique c'est que au moment où vous
avez quitté les affaires
tout allait tellement mieux et monsieur
monsieur le président caennais ma
lecture à moi et après tout il peut
arriver qu'elle diffère ma lecture à moi
ne me conduit pas à penser que au moment
où vous auriez quitté les affaires
tout allait mieux et j'ai le sentiment
mais peut-être est-ce une impression que
c'est ce qu'ont dit les français et donc
comme je suis un démocrate comme vous
j'écoute ce que disent les français et
et j'écoute et j'écoute et j'écoute avec
beaucoup d'attention
je me permets monsieur le président
kader de vous répondre non pas sur
l'ensemble des points que vous avez
soulevé sa 9ème internement pas possible
à ce stade mais de dire un mot sur la
retraite
vous nous dites monsieur le président
caennais que nous aurions tort
d'indiquer aux français que la mise en
place d'un âge d équilibre du système à
64 ans en 2027 que cette mise en place
d'un âge déquilibre à 64 ans en 2027
serait une offense faite à la situation
des françaises et des français qui
doivent pouvoir prendre leur retraite
dans de bonnes conditions mais vous même
monsieur le président caennais avaient
j'imagine je ne le sais pas je suis
certain que le compte rendu de l'époque
permettra de le dire vous avez je crois
approuvé une réforme qui avait pour un
pacte s'agissant des régimes du régime
général de faire en sorte que la durée
de cotisation s'allonge très nettement
très nettement de telle façon d'ailleurs
commencera entrera en application le 1er
janvier 2020 de telle façon d'ailleurs
que l'âge moyen de départ à la retraite
aujourd'hui
s'agissant du régime général ces
soixante trois ans et demi et que les
projections indiquent qu'avec la réforme
que vous avez
approuvé en 2014 l'âge moyen écoutez moi
bien monsieur le président caennais
l'âge moyen de départ à la retraite
s'agissant du régime général et du
régime général seulement mais c'est 80%
des français sera à 64 ans dans cinq ans
autrement dit monsieur kader vous êtes
en train de reprocher à ce gouvernement
de dire les choses de façon explicite
est de créer un système dans lequel nous
assumons les choses là où vous là où
vous avez mis en place un système qui
pour le régime général pas pour les
autres mais pour le régime général
conduit à une augmentation continue les
durées de cotisation pour arriver à un
âge moyen qui est exactement celui là eh
ben vous voyez monsieur le président
caennais
je trouve que cet échange est
intéressant et qu'il est bon que les
français longtemps monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre vous faites
référence à la réforme de marisol
touraine qui certes n'avait pas mis la
france dans la rue ça je vous le concède
je vous le concède par contre par contre
votre système sera que dans toutes les
hypothèses
les français travailleront plus sinon
ils gagneront moins ce qui n'était pas
le cas de la réforme de marisol touraine
et dans ce cadre là vous voulez encore
une fois avoir raison contre tout le
monde tout seul en permanence et cela
les français vous le reproche
ils vous le diront très prochainement
mais si la parole est au président
claude malhuret
pour le groupe les indépendants vous
avez la parole monsieur le premier
ministre la france est aujourd'hui
divisée en deux camps ceux qui râlent et
ceux qui râlent contre ceux qui râlent
ces derniers jours on a surtout entendu
les premiers je voudrais parler des
autres de tous les autres ceux qui ne
défilent pas qu'ils n'ont pas de
mégaphones pas de pancarte parce qu'ils
savent qu'un examen objectif des faits
est toujours trop long vo une banderole
ceux qui ne font pas grève et se font
parfois pour cela injurier ou crever
leurs pneus ce qui ne supportait plus de
voir que lorsqu'on a un problème avec le
gouvernement
on s'en prend aux travailleurs naufragé
dans des transports à l'arrêt aux enfant
se heurtant à des grilles d'écoles
fermées aux chefs de petites entreprises
je vois que les râleurs ne sont pas
seulement dans la rue
aux chefs de petites entreprises
supportant seul le coût de l'absentéisme
forcé de leurs employés aux commerçants
espérant rattraper les pertes subies
l'an dernier et qui voit s'annoncer pour
noël de nouvelles pertes au plus grand
profit d'amazon ceux à qui l'on dit que
le service public à une obligation de
continuité et qui constate que 90% des
grèves ont lieu dans le secteur public
ce qu'ils constatent que les soi disant
défenseurs du service public s'en
prennent en priorité aux usagers de ce
même service et que le baratin de la
grève au service de tous n'est que le
faux nez de la défense de privilèges
corporatistes
ces français-là sont beaucoup plus
nombreux que les grévistes mais comme
ils ne manifestent pas personne ne se
soucie d'eux et il continue de ramer en
attendant un métro qui ne viendra jamais
où un train qui sera supprimé et comme
si ça ne suffisait pas la cgt nous
annonce désormais le blocage des
raffineries
bonjour les fêtes de noël en famille
nicolas sarkozy avait réussi en 2007 à
faire voter une loi sur le service
minimum qui a fonctionné pendant
quelques années
elle est désormais bafouée et inopérante
ma question est la suivante monsieur le
premier ministre
premièrement pouvez-vous nous assurer de
la détermination du gouvernement
face au blocage présent est annoncée
deuxièmement n'est-il pas temps comme le
proposent certains de nos collègues sur
ses bancs de réfléchir à de nouvelles
dispositions sur le service minimum
garanti pour vous répondre la parole et
à monsieur le premier ministre
il est dit on
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président ma durée avec
votre style inimitable et d'ailleurs est
limité vous décrivez une réalité qui est
préoccupante
une réalité qui est préoccupante
la réalité qui fait que trop souvent
chacun se drapant dans ce qu'il
considère un droit et conduit à
méconnaître le droit d'un autre le droit
de grève et le droit de manifester sont
des libertés constitutionnellement
préserver et défendu et elles doivent
être respectées
nous le savons tous je le dis je le dis
et je l' ai toujours dit je ne crois pas
qu ici peut-être même moins qu'ailleurs
on puisse mégoter si vous me passez
cette expression avec une liberté
publique et constitutionnel mais aussi
bien que le droit de grève et le droit
de manifester
les principes de continuité des services
publics de liberté d'aller et venir de
liberté d'expression de liberté de
travailler et donc de ne pas faire grève
sont des principes qui ont la même
valeur
la même valeur est ce que je dénonce ça
n'est pas que certains fassent la grève
et que d'autres ne la fasse pas que
certains soutiennent les grévistes et
que d'autres les dénonce
ce que je regrette c'est que le choix
des uns ou des autres puissent passer
par la dénonciation des autres
nous vivons dans une démocratie nous
devons assumer nos choix et nos
positions ce qui font grève ont le droit
de le faire mais ils doivent le faire
conformément à la loi
menacer ceux qui ne font pas grève n'est
pas correct et est illégal et nous
savons et je ne dis pas que tous les
grévistes le font bien entendu bien
entendu mais nous savons que dans telle
ou telle entreprise nous le savons parce
que nous le voyons
parce que nous en avons des preuves des
images des films
nous savons que c'est mais ces pressions
existent elles ne sont évidemment pas
acceptable de la même façon tous les
mouvements qui consiste à nier la
reconnaissance et l'existence du droit
de grève sont à mon sens regretta ce que
je veux dire monsieur le président
malhuret
c'est que le gouvernement ne veut pas
opposer les français les uns aux autres
je ne suis pas dans la logique
consistant à dire qu'il y aura des
vainqueurs ou des vaincus je pense que
la solidarité nationale qui s'incarne
dans un régime universel de retraite est
exactement porteuse de la logique
inverse celle dans laquelle tous les
français quel que soit leur statut c'est
vrai quel que soit leur métier
c'est vrai contribuer à la retraite de
tous les français
ce système que nous voulons mettre en
place qui va prendre en compte des
droits nouveaux c'est le système non pas
des français contre les autres français
mais de l'ensemble des français
vis-à-vis des futurs pensionnés et aussi
vis-à-vis de ceux qui paieront les
futurs pensionnés et je veux rester dans
cette logique
vous avez raison les mouvements de grève
se double parfois pas toujours pas
toujours mais parfois de blocage le
blocage mesdames et messieurs n'est pas
autorisé par la loi la loi sur le droit
de grève n'autorise pas à bloquer tel ou
tel dépôt c'est illégal et donc cela
doit être proscrit elle n'autorise pas à
bloquer tel ou tel centre de stockage ou
de production c'est illégal et donc
nous faisons intervenir les forces de
l'ordre pour faire en sorte que ces
blocages ne puisse pas prévaloir
sané ça n'est pas toujours facile car
nous savons très bien
le risque nous savons très bien le
risque que nous courons lorsque nous en
cours lorsque nous engageons la force
publique de cette façon et donc ne
voulons pas céder aux provocations et
nous ne voulons pas qu'un incident
puisse ensuite développé le désert mais
je le dis clairement monsieur le
président malgré la grève c'est
constitutionnel
on y a le droit le blocage c'est
inconstitutionnel
on n'a pas le droit et la continuité du
service public c'est pas quand tout va
bien la continuité du service public
c'est justement le principe qui impose
aux fonctionnaires ou aux agents publics
de poursuivre leurs activités quand
c'est l'intérêt du service public des
françaises et des français et donc d'une
certaine façon
l'intérêt de la nation sur ce terrain
nous sommes évidemment déterminée a
rappelé les principes et le cas échéant
à en compléter à en compléter les
dispositions nécessaires mais je le dis
je le dis aussi monsieur le président
malgré nous connaissons tous le rythme
auquel les lois qui intervient dans la
matière doivent être discutés nous le
savons tous les grandes propositions qui
interviennent la veille d'un mouvement
de grève sont souvent des façons
d'attirer l'attention du public sur un
sujet est peut-être un peu moins une
façon de régler durablement une question
juridique délicate
la parole est maintenant président
philippe dallier pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président sur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre et concerne
également la réforme des retraites
monsieur le premier ministre vous aviez
prévenu les députés de la majorité hier
en disant qu'aujourd'hui il n'y aurait
pas d'annoncé magique dont acte le
ministre du budget et des comptes
publics répètent souvent ici lors des
débats budgétaires qu'il n'ya pas non
plus de chiffre magique et il a bien
raison
cependant après vous avoir écouté
attentivement ce midi
il nous manque quelques petits éléments
pour comprendre nous allons exactement
d'une part vous allez devoir
rééquilibrer le système de retraite
actuel dont le corps nous dit qu'il sera
déficitaire entre 10 et 17 milliards
d'ici 2025 et d'autre part vous allez
mettre en place progressivement le
nouveau système qui accorde des
garanties individuelles notamment aux
enseignants mais qui va également
accordé des droits nouveaux et je pense
aux mille euros de pension minimum pour
tous alors si l'on a bien compris que le
retour à l'équilibré du système actuel
sera la sphère des partenaires sociaux
avec l'âge pivot à 64 ans d'ici 2027 et
non 2025
vous n'avez rien dit monsieur le premier
ministre du coup des mesures de
transition et des mesures nouvelles ni
de la manière dont vous allez les
finances et voilà ma question on réponde
la parole et à monsieur le premier
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur m'interroger sur le
rythme auquel nous nous proposons de
basculer dans le régime futur et sur les
questions importantes d'équilibrage du
système actuel et du système futur c'est
beaucoup de questions et je reconnais
qu'elle ne sont pas simples
je voudrais essayer de répondre le plus
simplement possible dans le système
futur une fois que tout aura été mise en
place
la responsabilité reviendra c'est vrai
aux partenaires sociaux et au parlement
le système futur comme le système actuel
d'ailleurs il sera financé à 75% par des
cotisations et à 25% par l'impôt dès
lors qu'il est financé à 75% par des
cotisations et 25% par l'impôt il n'est
pas illégitime
ils ne semblent même nécessaire que les
partenaires sociaux soient représentés
actifs et centraux dans les décisions
qui sont prises et que le parlement soit
associé centrale aussi dans la
définition du pilotage de ces opérations
il reviendra à la gouvernance future de
fixer des règles d'équilibré par période
de cinq ans car comme le
haut-commissaire l'indiqué il nous
semble que assurer la modification des
éléments par période de cinq ans c'est
ne pas placer le système dans un
décalage ou dans un déséquilibre trop
durable et ça ne fait pas peser
la nécessité de l'adaptation sur une
seule année
il y à des pays dans lesquels la
nécessité de l'équilibré se fait année
par année je pense notamment à la suède
où il ya aussi un régime de
capitalisation à côté du régime de
répartition et bacchantes
quand il ya une retour un retournement
du cycle économique où une crise
financière
l'ajustement il doit se faire sur une
année et ça a conduit la suède en 2008
ou 2009 à faire baisser le niveau de ces
pensions nous ne voulons pas cela et
donc nous voulons un équilibrage sur
cinq ans pour faire en sorte que les
changements de cycles économiques
puissent être absorbée et lycées ça ça
reviendra à la gouvernance future
au fond on pourra jouer sur des
paramètres qui sont en vérité les mêmes
qu'aujourd'hui la durée du travail le
taux de cotisation le niveau des
pensions
mais nous aurons indiqué c'est la règle
d'or que le point ne baissera pas qu'il
devra évoluer dans le futur à la même
vitesse que l'évolution des salaires ce
qui est une grande garantie
vous le savez parfaitement pour les
retraités de demain pour les retraités
de demain voilà ça c'est le système
futur le déséquilibre actuel nous le
constatons il est lié au système tel
qu'il fonctionne depuis longtemps il y a
trois ans le corps qui est un institut
une institution parfaitement respectable
est d'ailleurs parfaitement respecté
disait que à l'horizon 2025
on était à l' équilibre les hypothèses
ont changé je ne prononce pas sur la
façon dont le travail est fait je sais
qu'il est bien fait néanmoins ce que
nous constatons c'est que quelques mois
après l'élection présidentielle le corps
a dit finalement l' équilibre ne sera
pas préservée et que lorsque j'ai
interrogé le corps pour justement mettre
tout sur la table pour dire la vérité
pour ne pas spéculer mais au contraire
montrer les projections les plus
récentes le corps nous a dit qu'il y
avait en fonction des hypothèses un
déséquilibre de l'ordre de 7 à 17
milliards qui était attendu et bien nous
devons le régler par en une fois pas en
une seule mesure mais nous devons dire
aux français comment progressivement
nous allons régler cette question d'un
déséquilibre qui est de l'ordre de 7 à
17 milliards par an 7 à 10 7 milliards
par an en 2025 mais qui s'accroît très
ensuite bon nous avons dit j'ai dit ce
matin que pour permettre la mise en
place du système futur nous proposions
que la trajectoire d' équilibre soit
commencée au 1er janvier 2022 et qu'elle
permette d'arriver à l'équilibré du sist
l'ancien en 2027 voilà c'est la
proposition que j'ai faite en écoutant
ceux qui disaient vous ne pouvez pas
faire commencer des mesures d' équilibre
au moment nous discutons du système
universel ce que je peux parfaitement
entendre et ce qui est probablement une
la meilleure position à adopter
il reviendra je les dis ce matin à la
nouvelle gouvernance de définir cette
trajectoire est de définir les
mécanismes qui permettent de la garantir
mais parce que je ne renoncerai jamais à
mes responsabilités
jamais j'ai dit que si cette trajectoire
n'était pas définie par un accord entre
les partenaires sociaux
alors le gouvernement assumerait ses
responsabilités et or a placé dans la
loi cadre qui sera examiné par le
parlement au premier semestre de l'année
2020 à l'assemblée nationale je l'espère
dans le premier trimestre au sénat dont
le second trimestre que la loi
prévoirait des mesures qui à défaut
s'appliquerait si la nouvelle
gouvernance n'arrivait pas à définir les
conditions du retour à l'équilibré c'est
ça que j'ai dit ce matin et ça se
passera par une augmentation par une
incitation pas par une obligation par
une incitation à travailler
progressivement
c'est vrai un peu plus longtemps
autrement dit monsieur le sénateur les
choses sont claires elles sont dites
nous ne nous payons pas de mots et nous
assumons nos responsabilités
c'est à ce prix que nous pourrons
construire un système universel
équitable et responsable
monsieur d'allier monsieur le président
le premier liste
merci de m'avoir répondu tout d'abord
mais vous ne m'avez pas répondu j'ai
bien compris qu effectivement les
partenaires sociaux devraient trouver le
chemin mais il ya par exemple pour les
enseignants l'augmentation des
traitements que vous allez devoir mettre
en oeuvre pour leur permettre
effectivement de bénéficier à terme d'un
même niveau de retraites combien a coûté
cette mesure elle va bien peser sur le
budget de l'état et elle va montrer en 1
valmont père le progressivement
président de la république avait dit 10
milliards si mes souvenirs sont bons il
ya quelques mois les 1000 euros minimum
pour tous
combien ça va coûter qui va l'assumer le
système ancien ou pas
voilà les questions que je vous pose est
alors le gouvernement a déjà abandonné
l'objectif du retour à l'équilibré des
comptes publics en 2029
la question c'est où allons nous dans
les cinq ans qui suivent
voilà la question qui est posée et
j'espère que d'ici le débat ici au mois
de février le parlement sera
parfaitement éclairé parce que voter une
loi cadre c'est bien mais sans en
comprendre les conséquences ça nous
paraît pas acceptable
merci la parole est à peu près collègues
had catherine loisier pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je vous proposais de parler
commerce international en octobre
dernier le président trump annonçait
plus de 7 milliards de dollars de taxes
punitives sur les produits européens
cette annonce intervenait après le feu
vert de l'om c'est l'institution ayant
évalué les dommages pour les états unis
du fait des subventions accordées à
airbus par l'union européenne
il s'agissait de la plus lourde sanction
jamais imposé par le mc mais les
européens aussi ont dénoncé plus de 19
milliards de dollars de subventions
troyer à boeing par le gouvernement
américain et le montant de ces sanctions
imposable par l'europe sur les
importations américaines sera connu
début 2020 aujourd'hui c'est la taxe e
gaffard qui fait planer un nouveau
risque de plus de 2 milliards de
sanctions douanières sur les produits
français
monsieur le ministre on va nous mener
cette escalade de sanctions il ya
quelques semaines vous avez déclaré nous
serons prêts avec nos partenaires
européens à y répondre de façon ferme
c'est taxation punitive à répétition
risque d'affecter durablement l'économie
globale et met déjà en difficulté un
grand nombre d entreprises françaises
les producteurs de vins français estime
le préjudice à plus de 250 millions
d'euros par an et ses acteurs
économiques craignent un effondrement
global de leurs activités d'abord des
pertes de ventes puis plus grave des
pertes de marché par des
déréférencements à l'appui il explique
que les sanctions étaient prononcés sur
des marchés pour lesquels les etats-unis
ont déjà des produits de remplacement
ces sanctions nous savons sont pourtant
à double tranchant même pour les états
unis les chaînes de production d2
constructeur aérien étant complètement
mondialisé avec de la sous traitance
dans tous les pays alors monsieur le
ministre que répondez vous aux
professionnels qui font aujourd'hui les
frais de ces dissensions et appelle les
autorités françaises et européennes à
négocier des solutions pour vous
répondre
la parole est aux milices de l'économie
et des finances bruno le maire monsieur
le ministre
madame la sénatrice la seule négociation
qui vaille c'est celle qui nous permet
d'avoir une taxation internationale des
gens du numérique à l' ocde accepté par
tous les pays de la planète
aujourd'hui la france accepte la russie
où j'étais fière l'acceptent lançant des
pays européens sont prêts à accepter la
solution à l' ocde
c'est aux états unis de savoir si oui ou
non ils sont prêts à accepter cette
solution internationale à le céder ou de
taxation du numérique
mais pour le coup jamais nous ne
renoncerons à ce que des géants du
numérique qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
américains ou européens ou chinois
continuent à exercer leurs activités à
faire des milliards d'euros de profits
sur le territoire français ou européens
et à payer des impôts dérisoire parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de présence physique
c'est une question de justice c'est une
question d'efficacité fiscale et il
n'est pas question pour la france je le
dis tout aussi nette que cela de se
coucher devant qui que ce soit alors que
nous défendons une proposition qui est
juste et qui est nécessaire pour mettre
en place une fiscalité internationale au
21e siècle il y à une taxe française qui
était adoptée aujourd'hui elle est mise
en oeuvre est ce qu'il ya de meilleur
solution oui je le redis c'est le cd eux
et nous l'avons accepté ces deux états
unis maintenant de nous dire si oui ou
non ils sont prêts à accepter cette
solution internationale qui serait de
loin la plus efficace si jamais
n'arrivions pas une solution a lancé des
oeufs
nous travaillons avec la commission
européenne avec le nouveau commissaire
européen paul jenkins ni à une nouvelle
solution européenne pour que ce soit
l'ensemble de l'union européenne qui à
nouveau refasse une proposition de
taxation des gens du numérique
quant aux sanctions elles sont
inacceptables elles sont inacceptables
endroit parce que notre taxe n'est pas
discriminatoire
elle touche aussi les entreprises
européennes est aussi une entreprise
chinoise
elles sont inacceptables parce que les
états unis sont des alliés et qu'on ne
se comporte pas comme ça entre
ils sont inacceptables parce que
l'économie mondiale a besoin d'autre
chose que d'un cycle de sanctions et de
riposte qui vont peser sur la croissance
internationale peser sur les emplois en
europe certainement mais aussi aux états
unis donc j'invite les états unis à
tenir la parole qu'ils ont fait à la
france en août en marge du g7 d'en
revenir aux négociations le cdo et
d'accepter cette solution internationale
de taxation des gens du numérique madame
loisier avec quelques secondes
samia n'a comme seul ministre qu'elles
sont inacceptables mais elle existe est
la vraie question c'est de savoir
aujourd'hui quelle régulation régulation
du commerce mondial avec aujourd'hui un
marché qui oscille entre des taxations
punitive et des exonérations de droits
de douane dans des traités de libre
échange merci la parole est à l'autre
collègue martha lévriers pour le groupe
de la république en marge de la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le haut
commissaire jean paul delevoye
aujourd'hui avoir 50 ans avoir changé
plusieurs fois de métier et vouloir
connaître le montant de sa pension
s'apparentera du masochisme avoir 40 ans
subir une carrière difficile précaires
ou haché et tenter d'estimer sa pension
invite à une dépression certaines avoir
30 ans et imaginer sa retraite
s'apparente plus au fantasme qu'au rêve
quant à être femme c'est avoir la
certitude d'une pension de retraite
inférieure de 40 2% à celle d'un homme
notre système fondé il ya plus de 70 ans
est devenue au fil des réformes une
jungle qui génère l'anxiété qui oppose
les français les uns aux autres plus que
lui qu'il ne les unit ans retrouvé l'adn
ne pouvait plus passer par des réformes
paramétriques depuis deux ans vous avez
réalisé une large concertation dont
l'organisation a été louée par les
partenaires sociaux puis plus récemment
par les français que vous avez
rencontrés au fil des réunions
organisées au travers du pays
tout ce travail a permis au premier
ministre et au gouvernement
de proposer un nouveau cadre qui va
refonder tout notre système il
s'organise autour de quatre piliers
l'universalité au travers d'un système
unique de cotisation par point les
quitter car chaque euro travail et donne
aura les mêmes droits à chacun la
gouvernance ouverte qui garantit la
prise en compte de tous la stabilité à
long terme et la certitude que la valeur
du point et les pensions progresseront
la solidarité par la suppression des 42
caisses la confortation de notre régime
de répartition la protection des
familles et des plus fragiles parce que
la solidarité est le ciment de la
réforme
et alors que depuis plusieurs semaines
des fêtes news et des simulateurs bidon
font florès
monsieur le ministre quels sont les
points saillants de vos propositions qui
démontre que cette refondation s'adresse
aussi aux plus fragiles et garantissent
véritable esprit de solidarité
je vous remercie pour vos répondre la
parole était aux commissaires en
retraite délégué auprès de la ministre
des solidarités de la santé de la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur monsieur ne devriez vous avez
raison d'indiquer qu' aujourd'hui
comprendre sa retraite des parcours
professionnels diverses est
effectivement compliqué je recevais
lundi la totalité des partenaires
sociaux et nous faisions la convergence
entre le résultat des plateforme
citoyenne et les consensus qui pouvait
se dégager des différents partenaires
sociaux ça aurait été très frappé qu' il
y a un fort soutien à la mise en place
d'un régime universel
ce qui ne veut pas dire unique ce qui
veut dire des règles les mêmes règles
pour tous et ce midi au conseil
économique social et environnemental
monsieur le premier ministre a rappelé à
quel point il y avait un attachement à
nos concitoyens d'une égalité de
traitement
les mêmes règles les mêmes devoirs
il ya une forte résonance dans l'opinion
la seconde c'est que si la retraite est
le reflet de votre travail et si le
système par points est très simple
aujourd'hui vous avez des revenus vous
acquérez des points vous ai dit chad et
vos points vous avez la liberté de
partie
il ya une très forte demande de
solidarité et nous avons été très frappé
de voir que plus les générations sont
jeunes plus elles sont demanderesse de
solidarité par rapport à celles et ceux
qui sont proches de la retraite et dans
les propositions qui ont été faites ce
midi par le premier ministre il y a
énormément de renfort des droits
familiaux pour les précaires pour les
femmes pour les femmes il y à des
simulations qui ont été faites et qui
montrent qu'effectivement nous allons
améliorer la pension moyenne des femmes
de 10 à 20% pour les génération 80 90 et
le minimum contributif correspond à une
attente profonde du monde agricole et du
bon d'artisans donc ce projet plus
simple plus juste plus solide plus
solidaire la parole est maintenant notre
collègue frédérique puissat pour le
groupe les républicains restent ici le
président à ma question s'adresse de
nouveau à monsieur le haut commissaire
en charge des retraites
une chose est certaine les régimes de
retraite de fait très fort mais je vous
le dis d'autant plus que notre famille
politique à assumer des réformes
courageuses dans ce domaine il ya eu la
réforme balladur
la réforme fillon la réforme woerth il
faut rendre à césar ce qui est à césar
si réforme ont sauvé de la faillite le
régime de retraite de nos compatriotes
car elles en ont eu le courage de
toucher à la durée des cotisations
même si ça ne plaît pas à tout le monde
sur ces ronds vous avez ce matin tenter
d'éclairer monsieur le premier ministre
le concitoyen sur votre projet au delà
des grands principes pas vraiment
nouveau sur lequel vous avez appuyé vos
propos je voudrais vous poser cinq
questions précises qui reste en surplus
en suspens la première à quel âge les
français pourront-ils bénéficier d'une
pension de reversions la deuxième
que devient dans l'autre réforme dans
votre réforme la majoration de
trimestres dont bénéficient les mères de
famille et elle supprimée que devient la
majoration de 10 % par par an pour les
familles de trois enfants
la troisième que deviennent les réserves
des régimes des salariés du privé
vous avez simplement évoqué l'avenir des
réserves des régimes des professions
libérales la quatrième le bonus malik
malus s'appliquera-t-il dès 2022
et si oui
s'appliquera-t-il aux régimes spéciaux
et enfin les salariés pourront-ils comme
aujourd'hui bénéficier d'une
reconstitution de carrière complète à 67
ans pour vous répondre la parole est au
haut commissaire auprès de monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice met la puce à la question
précise réponse précise
vous avez indiqué qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de réformes qui avaient
été faites et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
dire que pour les gouvernements de
gauche où les gouvernements de droite
il y avait des réformes qui ont apporté
à peu près 70 milliards soit de recettes
au plus soit de dépenses en moins ce qui
fait qu effectivement le régime actuel
est à peu près d' équilibre 03 05 % de
plus par contre il ya un certain nombre
de réformes qui méritait d'être corrigés
vous évoquez la réforme de monsieur
balladur sur les 70 milliards 35 ont été
apportées par une mesure qui passent
relativement anodine qui est
l'indexation de ce qu'on appelle les
salaires portés aux comptes sur
l'inflation ce qui revient à dire que si
vous avez 25 ans que vous acquérez des
droits que valent ces droits quarante
ans plus tard quand vous partez à la
retraite et le fait de les avoir
indexé sur l'inflation qui a globalement
un point de moins que l'évolution des
prix
vous êtes je réponds sur la réforme et
je dis que simplement non mais je
réponds aux réformes merci de
l'interrompre
parce que en l'été nous souhaitons
corriger ce 17 cette réforme qui ne nous
paraît pas juste parce qu'on aura été
trente ans aux quarante ans plus tard
vous perdez 25 à 30 % de vos droits et
nous allons le rectifier en mettant les
points acquis sur l'indexation sur les
salaires ce qui est une avancée
considérable y compris pour la fonction
publique
vous évoquez la réversion il y
actuellement 13 systèmes de reversions
13 systèmes de reversions et lorsque
nous avons consulté de concitoyens ainsi
que de partenaires sociaux ils ont tous
été favorable à la proposition qui
consistait à garantir 70
cent du revenu du dernier coupe et nous
réfléchissons et nous réfléchissons aux
voleurs à nation à partir de 55 ans
trois questions si vous reste à les y
encore quelques secondes et non c'est
une avancée considérable qui est souvent
soutenu
troisième élément les réserves ont été
très clairement indiquée par le premier
ministre ce matin ils étaient dans les
caisses des celles et ceux qui les
avaient constitué et quant au bonus
malus vous avez bien vu le dialogue que
nous souhaitons avoir avec les
partenaires sociaux pour faire en sorte
que dans la mesure d'âge équilibre qui
pourrait s'appliquer jusqu'en 2027
s'il y a des propositions alternatives
formulées par les partenaires sociaux
c'est là aussi le contrat de confiance y
compris dans l'agout maintenant conclut
nous sommes prêts les entends moi même
puis ça quelques fessées ministre
j'avais pris mon stylo pour noter les
réponses je range mon stylo je vous
reposerait les questions par écrit ou
par oral pour avoir des questions des
réponses plus précises
en tout cas il ya une chose qui est
certaine monsieur lévriers notre
collègue sénateur a parlé du simulateur
que tu es un simulateur qui avait été
mise en place mais syndicats mais
heureusement qu'ils ont mis en place un
simulateur
parce qu'aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
attend de ce gouvernement en attend un
simulateur qui nous permettent de savoir
combien de temps doit cotiser
quand est ce qu'on pourra partir à la
retraite et ce pour chaque français
pendant combien de temps va-t-on
percevoir une retraite selon la fameuse
règle d'or dont monsieur le premier
ministre nous expliquer sur quel
fondement elles existent parce qu'une
règle d'or en termes législatifs je ne
sais pas exactement ce que c'est merci
la parole est à notre collègue viviane
artigalas pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ma question porte sur la
réforme du calcul des aides au logement
que votre gouvernement va mettre en
place au 1er janvier prochain
celles ci seront désormais calculés en
temps réel sur la base des ressources du
team trimestre précédent et non plus sur
celle perçue deux ans plus tôt vous
présenter cette réforme comme une mesure
de justice
or l'économie qu'elle va engendrer 1,4
milliard d'euros' d'après vos
estimations se fera au détriment des
familles les plus modestes et des jeunes
qui entrent dans la vie active
une fois 2
plus ce sont précisément ceux qui ont le
plus besoin de justice sociale qui vont
faire les frais de votre politique
chacun sait que les jeunes de 18 24 ans
qui démarre leur vie professionnelle
très souvent avec des emplois précaires
ont les plus grandes difficultés à
accéder au logement les familles
modestes dont plus de la moitié
travaillent pourtant connaissent la même
situation et c'était précisément le
principe des apl qui permettait de les
soutenir pendant quelques temps encore
même si leur situation évoluer
positivement depuis les débuts du
quinquennat les aides au logement sont
la cible de votre gouvernement
déjà avec la baisse de 5 euros des apl
avec la suppression de la paix à
l'accession et aujourd'hui avec cette
réforme du mode de calcul
depuis 2010 est l'impact de ces réformes
s'élève déjà à 7 milliards d'euros
ce sont autant d'atteintes porté au
pouvoir d'achat des jeunes actifs et des
ménages les plus modestes
alors monsieur le ministre quelles
mesures d'accompagnement avez vous prévu
pour ces personnes qui vont brutalement
perdre leur apl et se retrouver dans les
plus grandes difficultés pour vour et
prom la parole est monsieur deux
normandies ministre délégué en charge de
la ville et du logement de la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame là la
sénatrice vous m'interrogez sur la
réforme des appels en temps réel et me
demander si c'est une réforme de justice
aujourd'hui je posais une question très
simple qui ici dans cet hémicycle peux
comprendre qu'on vous donne des appels
en fonction de qui vous étiez il y a
deux ans qui peut le comprendre parce
que la réalité elle est celle là
aujourd'hui on vous donne des appels en
fonction de qui vous étiez il ya deux
ans et donc vous prenez par exemple une
mère qui il y a deux ans étaient à temps
plein et qui nous rejoue aujourd'hui se
retrouvent à mi temps qu'il y a deux ans
était en couple qui aujourd'hui est une
mère célibataire dans cette mer
aujourd'hui elle n'a pas accès au niveau
d'appels auxquels elle aurait droit
et puis vous m'interrogez au cas
particulier sur les étudiants et les
jeunes actifs
je vais être très clair dessus pour les
étudiants cela ne change rien absolument
rien même c'est bénéfique pour les
étudiants parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
aviez des aberrations par exemple un
étudiant salarié pouvait avoir moins
d'appels qu'un étudiant qui n'était pas
salarié
et puis sur les jeunes actifs madame la
sénatrice
comment fonctionne le modèle aujourd'hui
parce que personne ne le dit
suffisamment mais prenez un jeune actif
qui lorsqu'ils étaient étudiants
n'avaient pas accès aux appels
un jeune actif qui lorsqu'ils étaient
étudiants n'avaient pas accès aux appels
elle m'a figurez vous que ce jeune actif
aujourd'hui ils devaient attendre deux
ans je dis bien deux ans pour pouvoir
bénéficier d'appels
monsieur le sénateur c'est totalement
vrai et vous pourrez le vérifier
et donc aujourd'hui vous aviez aussi un
autre cas un jeune actif par exemple qui
devenait indépendant même schéma on lui
a appliqué des forfaits évaluatif qui
faisait qu'il devait attendre 2 ans et
donc la réforme elle consiste à dire
effectivement si vous êtes un jeune
actif qui rentrait dans le monde du
travail qui avait un salaire et ben on
adapte votre appel en fonction mais l
inverse un jeune actif qui n'avaient pas
d'appel aujourd'hui on lui permet d'en
avoir
et donc c'est une réforme qui vise à
arfons des systèmes de protection pour
une protection à celles et ceux qui en
ont besoin
merci madame artigalas oui monsieur le
ministre vous ne m'avez pas absolument
pas convaincu votre réponse de combat
vous n'êtes donc vous n'avez pas répondu
à ma question parce que vous niez la
réalité de ce code des conséquences de
votre réforme
je ne vous ai pas interroger sur les
étudiants je le sais très bien ce qui
nous remontent dans nos territoires
c'est vraiment les conséquences de cette
réforme et les mesures d'accompagnement
que vous allez mettre en place et vous
n'allez pas en mettre en place puisque
vous nier le problème
il ya vraiment un réel décalage entre la
réalité de terrain et votre discours
et les personnes les plus modestes
sauront vous le reprocher encore une
fois pour comme tout ce qui concerne le
logement
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
alain larcher pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues l'usagé du transport
public augmente dans les habitudes des
français
réponse essentielle aux enjeux
environnementaux
la fiabilité du transport public sa
continuité sont les conditions de son
développement mais surtout une exigence
pour tous ceux dont c'est le seul moyen
de transport trop souvent et en
particulier depuis sept jours la réalité
est tout autre car si le droit de grève
est un principe fondamental de notre
démocratie ce que nous respectons il est
malheureusement devenu le droit de
bloquer trouvez-vous tolérable que bus
métro et rer ter transilien soit à
l'arrêt ou presque des heures
interminables de galère la boule au
ventre
matin et soir sous la pluie et dans le
froid pour aller gagner leur vie et le
droit de payer leurs impôts pour ceux
qui n'ont pas la chance d'habiter à
proximité de leur lieu de travail
c'est inadmissible le droit de grève
n'est pas le droit de bloquer le pays
ne pensez vous pas que ce qui est
possible pour la télévision publique
devrait l'être pour les transports
publics
alors oui ou non ne pensez vous pas
qu'il est temps de prévoir le droit un
service garanti aux heures de pointe
concilier en droit de grève et droit
d'aller travailler pour notre économie
comme l'ont fait nos voisins européens
comme le sénat vous le propose avec la
ppl retailleau pour vous répondre
la parole est à la secrétaire et après
les milices de la transition écologique
et solidaire
l'embargo vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice anne klein larcher je voudrais
d'abord excusé elisabeth bornes et jean
baptiste djebbari qui reçoivent
actuellement les dirigeants des
entreprises publiques de transports la
ratp et la sncf avant de s'entretenir
avec des organisations syndicales
vous l'avez signalé un mouvement social
affecte notre pays depuis le 5 décembre
et mobilise un certain nombre de
citoyens dans la rue et dans les
transports comme monsieur le premier
ministre vient de le dire yale quelques
minutes nous respectons le droit de
grève
nous respectons le droit de manifester
et de s'exprimer en france pour nos
concitoyens
nous sommes également sensible à la
situation de tous ceux qui ont besoin
d'aller travailler qui ont besoin de se
déplacer et qui connaissent des
difficultés
la situation est actuellement la
suivante nous avons environ un tiers des
transilien qui fonctionne en
ile-de-france deux lignes de métro
automatisé qui fonctionnent certaines
lignes qui fonctionne en horaires
décalés face à cette situation
ile-de-france mobilité s'est mobilisée
pour mettre en place des bus de
remplacement environ 220 bus
nous avons aussi facilité élargit les
possibilités de covoiturage en ouvrant
les fils de bus et les voies réservées
pour le covoiturage enfin nous avons
avec les entreprises comme l'a signalé
plusieurs fois muriel pénicaud
solliciter les entreprises pour qu'elles
soient ouvertes aux possibilités de
télétravail qui permettent à nos
concitoyens de trouver la bonne
articulation dans cette période de
mobilisation
enfin suite au discours de monsieur le
premier ministre ce matin devant le
conseil économique social et
environnemental
la réforme des retraites a été posée
dans ces trois grandes lignes
l'universalité l'équité et la
responsabilité
madame hadja larcher
madame la ministre était pourtant sam je
demandais de répondre par oui ou par non
aujourd'hui quelques milliers de
grévistes paralyse 27 millions d'actifs
cela coûte 400 millions d'euros par jour
aux entreprises
avez vous conscience de l'exaspération
des français les entendez-vous avec
bruno retailleau nous proposons une loi
pour sortir la france de l'ornière et
lui éviter l'impasse entre les
atermoiements dans marche et la faillite
avec le rassemblement national
ce que vous orchestrez savamment c'est
dans notre adn de républicains de
trouver des solutions pour ne pas
aggraver davantage la situation de la
france en europe et dans le monde
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue loïc
hervé pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre le 5
septembre dernier
vous annonciez un plan de lutte contre
les violences subies par les sapeurs
pompiers
sans même attendre la remise des travaux
conduits ici au sénat par catherine
tremblay patrick kmm ekanè rémois même
sur le sujet la mesure phare de votre
plan était la mise en place de caméras
piétons cette mesure est bonne mais elle
n'est pas à portée seulement votre
crédit la loi prévoyant le dispositif
est d'ailleurs d'origine sénatoriale à
l'initiative de notre collègue jean
pierre decool et son décret
d'application était déjà pris depuis
plusieurs semaines au moment de l'
annonce
mais rassurez vous monsieur le ministre
si vous étiez en passe d'idées neuves
alors nous en aurions pour vous dans
notre rapport violence contre les
sapeurs-pompiers 18 propositions pour
que cesse l'inacceptable ce rapport a
été adopté ce matin par la commission
des lois du sénat
alors monsieur le ministre honnête vous
de la mise en oeuvre des engagements que
vous avez pris devant les
sapeurs-pompiers et surtout comment
envisagez-vous d'intégrer les
propositions opérationnelles que le
sénat formule pour vous répondre la
parole et au secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur laurent
nyonnaise monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur loïc avait effectivement vous
avez raison de souligner le problème des
agressions de sapeurs pompiers qui est
un problème très grave en 2018 on a eu
en moyenne cinq agressions par jour
c'est tout à fait inacceptable souvent
lors des sorties de secours à personnes
la plupart du temps d'ailleurs les
auteurs sont les personnes qui elles
mêmes sont secourus
j'ai pris connaissance monsieur le
rapporteur de la mission d'information
sur la sécurité des sapeurs pompiers des
propositions bien évidemment avec
beaucoup d'intérêt vous dire que vous me
temps c'est un peu sur les caméras
piétons mais vous savez très bien qu'en
matière de sécurité des sapeurs pompiers
il ya bien d'autres choses qui ont été
faites
oui les caméras piétons oui la fermeté
des parcs et sous l'autorité de la garde
des sceaux avec une réponse pénale très
forte
le dépôt de plainte ouvert aux sapeurs
pompiers dans les centres de secours
domiciliation possible
dans les sdi les protocoles
d'intervention dont monsieur le
président caennais d'ailleurs salué pour
le département du nord
tout l'intérêt tout l'importance août
tout le caractère opérationnel de ces
protocoles entre policiers gendarmes
sapeurs-pompiers pour intervenir dans
les zones délicates ça sur des mesures
concrètes elles sont en place vous avez
effectivement une 18 propositions madame
la sénatrice trembler les avait annoncé
quand nous étions passés au budget sans
vouloir d'ailleurs mme en révéler la
teneur exacte mais je découvre en lisant
ces propositions que fort heureusement
un certain nombre sont déjà mises en
oeuvre
heureusement et d'autres vont être mises
en oeuvre je peux vous rassurer le seul
sénateur
je pense à la sensibilisation des jeunes
publics
c'est ce que nous faisons à marseille
avec les cadets chez les marins pompiers
je pense aux formations des sapeurs
pompiers pour avoir des stratégies
d'évitement pour être dans l'auto
l'autoprotection tout cela nous allons
le mettre en oeuvre quand encore une
fois cela n'est pas déjà mis en oeuvre
alors ces propositions nous allons les
étudier avec beaucoup d'intérêt monsieur
le sénateur je peux vous le confirmer
comme vous le savez nous allons créer
également un observatoire national qui
aura vocation à recenser l'ensemble des
agressions mais aussi l'ensemble des
bonnes pratiques pour pouvoir les
généraliser sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
je crois que ce sujet très sérieux ils
méritent aucune polémique il mérite
beaucoup d'action et le gouvernement et
toutes engagées dans cette action sur le
carré président merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
j'étais loin de voûte ans et je suis
simple je vous lance est simplement ils
attendaient simplement une perche sur
une question où nous d'ailleurs sur
laquelle nous sommes d'accord je crois
notre exemple en 2016 la réforme de la
pfr versé au sapeur pompier volontaire à
ses économies et 30 millions d'euros à
l'état il était convenu que cet argent
soit reversée aux 10 pour investir dans
le domaine de la sécurité notamment des
pompiers ça fait partie des choses
madame tremblay a évoqué lors de
l'examen du projet de finances une forme
de hold up
ça fait partie de cet argent sonnant et
trébuchant qui à pied dans le domaine
des sapeurs vente et qu'il s'agit
d'investir et par ailleurs vous savez
que cette crise liée aux violences sur
les sapeurs pompiers elle risque de
mettre aussi en cause notre modèle du
volontariat et je sais que la question
notamment de du confortement au niveau
européen de ce modèle là nous tient
énormément à coeur
ici mon cher collègue la parole et à
notre collègue laurent duplomb pour le
groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président c'est à vous
monsieur le premier ministre que
j'adresse cette question c'est à quatre
lettres qui résonne comme une question
controversée dans la tête des français
c'est à l'assemblée nationale que le
texte a été ratifiée en juillet malgré
la bronca qu'il a suscité même au sein
de votre propre majorité
c'est à quelle date monsieur le premier
ministre que vous allez enfin programmé
l'étude du texte de ratification devant
le sénat prendre la parole et aux
milices de l'europe des affaires
étrangères aujourd'hui le drian ne venez
pas reçu le président monsieur le
sénateur du plomb nous ne sommes pas en
retard
quand je regarde quand je regarde
l'agenda au niveau européen sur 27 ou
sur 28 comme vous le souhaitez 13 l'ont
ratifié et tous les autres sont en
discussion de ratification des grands
pays comme l'allemagne comme l'italie
sont en discussion est en processus de
ratification
donc nous ne sommes pas en retard le
processus législatif suivra son cours et
la date d'examen par votre assemblée
sera fixé au début de l'année prochaine
mais puisque vous me donnez l'occasion
et comme il y a moyen maintenant de
comparer puisque il y à une mise en
oeuvre provisoire de cet accord nous
pouvons désormais comparer les neuf
premiers mois de 2010 neuf avec des neuf
premiers mois de 2010 est avant la mise
en oeuvre et et je constate que les
exportations de biens de la france vers
le canada en comparaison exportations de
biens ont augmenté de 19%
donc c'est plutôt gagnant et que par
ailleurs dans le même temps nos
importations ont diminué de 6 5% et nos
entreprises profitent de nombreux
secteurs de cet accord pour l'instant
avait raison accord provisoire et par
ailleurs je vous fera observer monsieur
le sénateur qu'aucune des filières
agricoles sensible qui avait été
identifié par vous-même et même au débat
à l'assemblée nationale n'a subi de
conséquences négatives du ceta le boeuf
canadien n'a pas inondé comme le
craignait le marché européen et nos
règles sanitaires sont restés pleinement
préservée et je voudrais vous faire une
observation finale dans votre
département
monsieur le sénateur les produits
d'importation agro alimentaires en
provenance du canada ont baissé depuis
l'entrée en vigueur du c'est à monsieur
du plomb ces temps malheureusement cette
réponse sans annonce de date précise que
je pouvais m'attendre
c'est un manque criant de courage une
fois de plus que votre gouvernement que
je pouvais aussi m'attendre c'est à une
manipulation malhonnête que nous pouvons
nous attendre
car en effet même sans ratification du
sénat
l'accord reste en vigueur comme depuis
24 mois et pour une durée illimitée
c'est un exemple une fois de plus d'un
sénat bafoués que nous pouvons nous
attendre et encore plus que cela c'est
aux français que vous faites un énième
pied-de-nez c'est à des produits issus
d'une agriculture que les français ne
veulent pas chez nous que vous allez
continuer d'ouvrir les portes créant une
concurrence déloyale de nos produits
français c'est tout cela que les
français ne veulent plus alors c'est à
vous monsieur le ministre que je demande
de prendre vos responsabilités dans cet
hémicycle devant les représentants des
français annoncée vite la date exacte de
l'examen au sénat du ceta car cela vous
en aurez
merci la parole est à l'autre collègue
guillaume hardel pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre des solidarités de la santé
depuis mon arrivée au sénat en 2014 je
n'ai eu de cesse d'alerter les
gouvernements successifs sur la
situation du centre hospitalier louis
constant fleming de saint martin mais
interpellation portait soit sur la
situation financière et budgétaire soit
sur les conditions d'exercice de la
médecine et la qualité des soins
madame la ministre je vous ai
régulièrement est tenue informée au
travers des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement ou par courrier de
situation qui ne pouvait me laisser
insensible
et je tiens d'ailleurs à vous remercier
à vous renouveler pardon mes
remerciements pour vos réponses sur les
difficultés apportée à la question des
médecins urgentistes récemment un
infirmier anesthésiste a tenté de mettre
fin à ses jours au sein même du bloc
opératoire
ce nouveau drame illustre une fois
encore la tension exacerbée qui règne au
sein du personnel médical du centre
hospitalier la rsa a été sensibilisée un
changement de direction a été effectué
et une administration provisoire a été
mis en place pour autant force est de
constater que la situation est devenue
insoutenable
aussi madame la ministre avec toutes les
précautions et les réserves d'usagé
pouvez-vous rassurer la population saint
martinoise que comptez vous faire pour
que la qualité des soins et la sécurité
des patients soit garanti et pour éviter
que ne se reproduise une situation
similaire à celle qui s'est produite il
y a quelques années au centre
hospitalier universitaire de rouen pour
vous répondre la parole interrogée mme
la ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame bizarre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur guillaume arnal
merci de me poser cette question et je
comprends l'inquiétude dont vous faîtes
vous faites le porte-parole aujourd'hui
et le drame dont vous fait écho ne peut
que nous alerter nous émouvoir
deux ans après le passage de l'ouragan
herman la reconstruction est toujours en
cours dans votre île dans l'hôpital
comme pour les autres structures et vous
l'avez rappelé le centre hospitalier
louis constant fleming a été placé sous
administration provisoire proviseur
depuis le mois d'avril dernier
sa décision a été prise face à la
situation extrêmement dégradée de
l'établissement en termes de trésorerie
de recouvrement mais aussi de conflits
récurrents en interne
mes services ont pu prendre connaissance
des premières conclusions de
l'administration de l'administration
provisoire
il ya quelques semaines un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements ont été
identifiés et confirmés il nous faut
apporter maintenant les solutions je
pense par exemple à la rédaction d'un
projet médical qui n'existe pas pour
l'île de saint martin le centre
hospitalier dispose d'atouts très
important en termes de compétences
médicales et chirurgicales et j'avais eu
l'occasion de rencontrer des personnels
dans la semaine qui a suivi remis et je
connais leur engagement alors qu'il y
avait des pillages et que l'hôpital
était partiellement détruit donc je le
rappelle il s'agit du principal
établissement sur l'île de saint martin
je sais qu'un grand nombre de
professionnels de cet établissement sont
attachés à leur établissement ils sont
en capacité de réaliser des efforts afin
d'assurer sa pérennité le ministère
aujourd'hui et l'agencé régionale de
santé vont apporter est accompagné par
dons vont continuer à accompagner la
mise en oeuvre de toutes les
préconisations de l'administration
provisoire
vous pouvez compter sur ma vigilance
pour cet établissement
il est primordial que des saint
martinois retrouve la confiance dont ils
ont besoin merci pierre bel oui madame
la ministre vous avez souvent été à
l'écouté de mes préoccupations
mais je voulais vous entendre
aujourd'hui encore pour assurer cette
population qui dans l' angoisse parce
qu'aujourd'hui des professionnels
ce télescope pour des raisons autres que
médicales
alors je compte sur votre vigilance
madame la ministre merci encore par
l'état notre collègue éric kerrouche
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
la parole monsieur le président madame
ministre chers collègues il ya un
décalage permanent entre le discours
empreint d'un vernis social du
gouvernement et la réalité qui n'est
celle que d'un triste libéralisme à tout
crin
ces dernières jours voir ces dernières
heures des millions de français ont
compris que le vrai sens des initiales
lrm c'était la retraite en moins
probablement pour privatiser plus au
départ du quinquennat on aurait pu
parier sur de la maladresse comme ces
cinq euros prix aux titulaires de l'apl
alors que les français les plus riches
gagnent et que chacun 1,7 million
d'euros par an avec les sf et la flat
tax
quant à la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation c'est huit milliards
d'euros pour les 20 % les plus aisés et
0% et 0 euros par don pour les 20% les
plus pauvres
une mesure présentée comme sociale qui
fragilisera avant tout les collectivités
que dire de la désindexation des
prestations sociales ou de l'assurance
chômage qui fera 1,3 million de perdants
il semble donc que socialement avec vous
il y a toujours les vaincus et les
vainqueurs mais vous n'êtes au chevet
que des derniers avec vous l'état est
comme amputé sa main gauche celle de
l'état providence
je souhaite aborder un exemple
révélateur en caressant l'espoir que
vous me démentirait lors des assises de
l'eau de 2018 le premier ministre a
annoncé la volonté de l'exécutif je cite
d'accélérer le déploiement de la
tarification sociale de l'eau à
destination des populations les plus
fragiles et la mise en place d'un chèque
au sur le modèle du chèque énergie là
encore beau discours utile d'autant que
le nombre de français pour lesquels la
facture d'eau et d'assainissement
dépasserait le seuil d'acceptabilité
pardon
et 2 2 millions la généralisation de la
tarification sociale de l'eau a été
adopté au sénat et à l'assemblée
mais le chèque hausse et si j'ose dire
évaporée du dispositif et la loi de
finances n'a pas corrigé cet oubli donc
ma question à damas ministre est la
suivante comment allez vous accompagner
les collectivités locales dans la
généralisation de la tarification
sociale de l'eau pour lutter contre la
précarité hydrique
allez-vous mettre en place à chaque os
ou faire supporter aux collectivités
locales
vos ambitions sociales bref faire payer
la solidarité par les autres on répondre
la parole et à la secrétaire d'état est
venue elle vers dont vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur kerrouche il n'y a aucun
décalage entre le discours et les actes
ni en général ni sur la tarification
sociale de l'eau
la tarification sociale de l'eau est
issu de la loi brottes de 2013 sous
forme d'expérimentation
elle a d'ailleurs été reconduite par la
loi de finances 2010 9 jusqu'à 2021
c'est une expérimentation qui a bien
fonctionné
il ya d'ailleurs deux territoires dans
votre département les landes monsieur le
sénateur qui se sont engagés dans cette
expérimentation 50 collectivités près de
15 millions de personnes couvertes un
montant moyen de 244 euros par an par
ménage et beaucoup de dispositions
diverses d'échec des remises d
accompagnement particulier aux économies
d'eau ont été déployés par les
collectivités territoriales
nous avons souhaité la généralisation le
premier ministre l'avait annoncé à la
fin de la première phase d assises de
l'eau cette génération cette
généralisation a été votée elle a été
proposée par le gouvernement dans la loi
portée par sébastien lecornu la loi
engagement et proximité elle a été votée
à l'unanimité et la commission mixte
paritaire se tient précisément
aujourd'hui à 17h j'espère que cette
disposition sera maintenu
la tarification sociale de l'eau
c'est un service public qui dépendent
des collectivités territoriales comme
vous le savez très bien
vous êtes d'ailleurs vous comme nous
attacher à la libre administration des
collectivités locales autant nous
pouvons
des chaque collectivité a trouvé ses
modalités de généralisation autant
l'état ne se substituera pas en mettant
en place un chèque aux uniformes
nationale parce que la tarification de
l'eau est différente par tous parce que
le prix de l'eau est différent par tous
et parce que la solution va être trouvée
localement sous la responsabilité de
chaque collectivité c'est d'ailleurs en
ce sens que cet amendement a été proposé
et qu'il a été voté je le redis à
l'unanimité sur tous les bancs merci la
parole et à notre collègue michel
forissier pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
le ministre du travail à qui je souhaite
un prompt rétablissement
madame le ministre votre gouvernement a
décidé de reprendre la main sur le
pilotage de l'apprentissage au niveau
national en supprimant toute régulation
fonctions qui étaient exercées par les
rayons aujourd'hui l'association des
régions de france tire la sonnette
d'alarmé en attirant l'attention sur
l'évolution des choix de l'orientation
sur les métiers qui tend à accentuer une
inéquation entre l'offre et la demande
sur le marché du travail ce qui ne va
pas dans le sens de régler le problème
crucial des postes non pourvus
madame le ministre allez-vous prendre
cette situation compte et redonner une
compétence de régulation région qui en
raison de leur compétence économique
pourrait travailler avec les branches
professionnelles et anticiper en
orientant les choix de formation sur les
métiers créateur d'emplois aujourd'hui
la réalité est que les entreprises
peinent à recruter les candidats à
l'apprentissage se retrouve devant de
multiples interlocuteurs et ont du mal à
entrer dans le dispositif les apprentis
les plus défavorisés ont besoin
un accompagnement pour trouver un
employeur trouver un le mans trouver un
hébergement et faire des démarches pour
obtenir les aides nécessaires et pour
finir où en êtes vous avec les
négociations qui doivent s'engager avec
les régions de france pour les
compensations qui d'après les comptes
vous leur devez pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la milice du
travail que je remercie d'être présente
ici dans cet hémicycle particulièrement
et à qui je souhaitais meyer le
président monsieur le président vous
motorisera ne pas me lever
exceptionnellement il ya eu un accident
du travail
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur forissier d'abord
je voudrais dire que et vous le savez je
suis très attaché au partenariat avec
les collectivités territoriales sur tous
les sujets d'emploi de formation et
d'insertion
c'est ce que nous faisons dans les
missions locales c'est ce que nous
faisons dans la préfiguration du service
public de l'insertion c'est ce que nous
faisons dans le plan d'investissement
compétences sont plus de 6 milliards
d'euros qui sont transférées aux régions
dans une approche partenariale
c'est donc avec plus de déceptions que
que de colère que je me permet peut-être
de rectifier de compléter vos
informations
la loi pour la liberté de choisir son
avenir professionnel
promulguée le 5 septembre 2018 est déjà
largement en vigueur et produit des
premiers résultats nous sommes d'accord
ce ne sont que des premiers résultats
mais nous avons au mois de juin une 458
milles apprentis on en a jamais eu
autant en france 8,4 pour cent et il ya
la plupart des mesures sont en vigueur
depuis le début de l'année toutes les
simplifications pour les entreprises la
d'unique l'embauchent tout au long de
l'année
les horaires de travail les conditions
de travail sont en vigueur depuis le 1er
janvier toutes les aides aux apprentis
aussi permis comme comme salaire mais la
mesure phare ça a été celle qui a fait
sauter le verrou il y avait un désaccord
avec les régions là dessus le verrou
pour la mise en plaques récurrente des
cfa et là c'est une dynamique
extraordinaire
initié par les régions les branches les
collectivités territoriales puisque ce
sont plus de 500 cfa que ce soit
enregistrée depuis le
début de l'année de la même façon le
coup au contrat est déjà en application
il a été avancé de trois mois car les
cfa nous l'ont demandé les entreprises
les jeunes et les cfa plébiscitent cette
réforme il ya + 27 % d'apprentis ou chez
les compagnons 17% dans les maisons
familiales rurales plus de 10 % dans
l'industrie
nous avons un seul sujet les 500
millions d'euros que le premier ministre
s'est engagé à transférer aux régions le
seront dès que l'assemblée des régions
de france n'aura proposer cette
répartition mais ouvrons ensemble pour
que sur ces sujets les régions qui
aujourd'hui ont baissé fortement les
financements des efforts en fin d'année
alors qu'ils ont les financements les
plus importants qui n'ont jamais eu ne
pratique pas la terre brûlée vont
ensemble monsieur for him
madame la ministre comme le sénat vous
l'avais proposé lors de nos débats sur
la loi pour la liberté de choisir son
avenir professionnel
je vous demande de revoir son alignement
votre position est de redonner aux
réunions une vraie compétence de
régulation vous demander aux régions de
s'investir et en même temps vouloir
retirer une compétence c'est d'une
incohérence totale au niveau de votre
gouvernement
il vaut absolument que cette compétence
de régulation et d'accompagnement de
reviennent aux régions parce qu'en
raison de leur compétence économique et
dans l'esprit d'une nouvelle étape de la
voie de la décentralisation il est
nécessaire que votre gouvernement
considère les régions comme des
partenaires et non aux concurrents voir
des ennemis
merci mesdames messieurs les ministres
merci les prochaines questions
d'actualité au gouvernement auront lieu
mercredi 18 décembre à 15 heures la
séance va être suspendue elle sera
reprise à 16h35 pour la proposition de
loi tendant à protéger les mineurs des
usages dangereux du protoxyde d'azoté
notre séance est suspendue pour 15
minutes
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin des questions
d'actualité une séance placée sous le
signe de la réforme des retraites passée
le temps des annonces étaient venus
celui à des explications
le premier ministre a eu faire face aux
réactions à chaud des sénateurs alors à
gauche de l'hémicycle la colère était de
mise pour la présidente du groupe
communiste comme pour le président du
groupe socialiste
là je cite ligne rouge a été franchie
une position qu'il partage avec les
syndicats vent debout contre la réforme
des retraites qui plus est depuis les
annonces d'edouard philippe ils sont
notamment contre la mise en place d'un
âge pivot fixé à 64 ans comme l'a
confirmé ce midi
edouard philippe qui a répondu aux
accusations de patrick kanner tout à
l'heure dans l'hémicycle en l'écoutent
projection a dit qu'avec la réforme que
vous avez approuvé en 2014
l'âge moyen écoutez moi bien monsieur le
président caennais l'âge moyen de départ
à la retraite
s'agissant du régime général et du
régime général seulement mais c'est 80%
des français sera à 64 ans dans cinq ans
autrement dit monsieur kader vous êtes
en train de reprocher à ce gouvernement
de dire les choses de façon explicite
est de créer un système dans lequel nous
assumons les choses là où vous là où
vous avez mis en place un système qui
pour le régime général pas pour les
autres mais pour le régime général
conduit à une augmentation continue des
durées de cotisation pour arriver à un
âge moyen qui est exactement celui là
sur les bancs de la droite les annonces
d'edouard philippe n'ont pas non plus
convaincu
on a toujours les mêmes inquiétudes
combien ça coûte
car toutes ces mesures ont un prix et le
premier ministre n'en a pas parlé ce
matin mais il n'a pas non plus répondu
donner de précisions chiffrées
tout à l'heure aux sénateurs et l'ère
philippe dallier
alors reste un point qui a été abordé
tout à l'heure pendant ces questions
d'actualité et pas des moindres la grève
puisqu'elle concerne concerne plusieurs
millions de français puisqu'elle
elle paralyse une bonne partie du pays
alors une réalité préoccupante selon les
mots du premier ministre qui a rappelé
tout à la fois la nécessité de préserver
le droit de grève le principe de
continuité du service public la liberté
d'aller et venir celle de travail et se
limitent le blocage alors edouard
philippe n'a pas fini d'être préoccupés
puisque après ces annonces le climat
social risque de se détériorer encore
plus qu'il ne l'est actuellement bien
qu'il ait est a indiqué je cite que sa
porte était ouverte aux partenaires
sociaux
merci beaucoup à l'iss pour ce
décryptage de la séance de questions
d'actualité qui ont effectivement été
très largement consacrée à la question
des retraites est tout de suite
eh bien on va rejoindre alexandre
poussard alexandre car vous êtes avec le
haut-commissaire aux retraites jean paul
delevoye
oui jean paul delevoye on l'a entendu
dans cette séance de questions
d'actualité
edouard philippe a dit que sa porte
était ouverte ça m'a été tendu aux
syndicats mais du côté des syndicats et
bien ils sont mécontents par ses
annonces sur la réforme des retraites et
pour le patron la cfdt laurent berger
une ligne rouge a été franchie qu'est ce
que vous répondez à laurent berger
vous connaissez depuis deux ans la
qualité de dialogue social que j'ai avec
les organisations syndicales
si ça continue parce que nous avons
énormément de sujets sur la table de
manlay les transitions les conversions
mais aussi il y a dans ce projet de
régime universel une contribution
extrêmement importante de la notamment
des syndicats comme la cfdt régime
universel régime à points
beaucoup de solidarité sont des demandes
extrêmement fortes de la cfdt
il y a pour reprendre l'expression de
laurent berger une opposition par
rapport à 7 h des équilibres qui était
d'ailleurs en débat depuis très
longtemps puisque c'est l'été voulait
garder une référence durée de cotisation
individuelle et nous avions mis sur la
table une référence d'âge collective qui
avait davantage et en même temps
d'annuler l'âge d'annulation de la
décote qui correspondait à une réponse
notamment de 20% des femmes qui était
d'aller jusqu'au bout et aussi aux
cadres qui rentrait tard sur le banc du
travail de pour voir partir un peu plus
tôt sans malus et donc je ne désespère
pas qu'après un temps d'appropriation
d'analystes de recul nous puissions voir
très concrètement comment
responsabiliser comment jouer cette
responsabilisation des partenaires
sociaux puisque le premier ministre a
proposé d'une gouvernance des
partenaires sociaux et je n'ai cessé
d'inviter à trouver la juste
articulation entre le gouvernement le
parlement et les partenaires sociaux
le premier ministre a aussi indiqué que
sur le point il y avait aussi une
capacité pour les partenaires sociaux de
peser sur la valeur du point sur son
indexation sur son évolution est donc au
coeur du contrat social de la dation au
coeur de cette cohésion générationnel
les partenaires ce choc qui représentent
75 % des revenus ont un rôle déterminant
à jouer je ne désespère pas de pouvoir
renouer un dialogue sur un certain
nombre de sujets cruciale pour ce
système universel très bien autre
question juste un mot sur la polémique
qui vous concerne monsieur
le voit sur vos liens avec le monde de
l'assurance que vous avez oublié de
déclarer à la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique
certains parlent de conflit d'intérêts
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à bord
j'ai reconnu cette ambition c'était à un
poste d'administrateur bénévoles sur un
organisme de formation puisque je suis
très impliquée dans la formation
notamment des jeux dans les quartiers
défavorisés etc etc
et chacun sait que parce que vous vous
occupez des jeunes et notamment sur le
métier d'assureur ça n'a rien à voir
avec le lobby des assureurs vous voyez
bien au contraire nous avons mis en
place un système de répartition le plus
élevé du monde qui réduit donc d'autant
plus la place laissée à la
capitalisation
donc aucun lien avec le lobby de
l'assurance non et puis je vous dois
vous dire que dès que j'ai appris cela
j'ai pris mes décisions et j'ai
immédiatement abandonner ses bandas que
évidemment jeu j'avais omis et donc j'ai
fait je suis quelqu'un de transparent de
francs et lorsqu'il y est une erreur je
n'aurais pas et lorsqu'il y a des
décisions à prendre je les assume très
bien merci beaucoup aux enseignes de loi
nous avons répondu merci beaucoup
alexandre pour cette réaction de jean
paul delevoye on va continuer à faire
bien le débrief de cette séance
largement consacrée à la question des
retraites avec être invitée sur ce
plateau christian navarre bon jour en
jour vous êtes si n'attriste l ère des
hauts-de-seine vice présidente de la
commission des finances également avec
nos bernard jomier vous allez au
sénateur apparenté au ps de paris membre
de la commission des affaires sociales
également avec nous jade azab vous êtes
président d'honneur du parlement des
étudiants il ya eu quelques mots
d'ailleurs d'edouard philippe pour les
étudiants dans son discours à midi on va
reparler et enfin à nos côtés jean marc
gabouty vous êtes sénateur rdse de la
haute-vienne vice-président du sénat et
membre de la commission des finances je
vais vous faire parler dans un instant
mais d'abord priorité la salle des
conférences
on va se rendre pour entendre philippe
dallier car lui aussi a tout à l'heure
interpellé le gouvernement autour de la
réforme des retraites et avec cette
question comment on finance alexandre
ans et où philippe dallier finalement la
droite et a l'air assez satisfaite par
cette réforme régime à points
allongement de la durée de travail mais
il ya un problème de financement vous
n'avez pas de réponse sur le coup c'est
la question que j'ai posée aux produits
et il n'a absolument pas répondu tout le
monde comprend bien que pour régler le
problème qui va être posée aux
enseignants qui eux risque effectivement
de perdre beaucoup en termes de pensions
si jamais leur traitement n'est pas
augmenté de manière significative
ça va avoir un coût de combien c'est la
question que je posais j'ai pas eu de
réponse président de la république avait
le 10 10 milliards d'euros par an il ya
quelques mois je n'ai pas de
confirmation de ce chiffre
ensuite ne serait-ce que la mesure qui
va consister à instaurer un minimum pour
tous de 1000 euros sur les retraites va
certainement avoir un coût important
combien comment cela sera-t-il financer
nous n'en savons strictement rien savez
ce gouvernement a déjà abandonné il ya
un an l'objectif du retour à l'équipe
des comptes publics en 2022 on n'en
parle plus ce que je vois ça cumulé ce
sont les factures que ce gouvernement
vers l'essai après 2022 10 milliards
d'euros pour la taxe d'habitation
peut-être 10 milliards d'euros pour les
traitements les enseignants le
financement de l'anru pour 1 milliard
tout ça est en train de s'additionner
et donc si on finance toutes ces mesures
nouvelles parts du déficit et de la
dette
je pense qu'il vaudrait mieux le dire
tout de suite aux français sur le fond
de la réforme
ce régime universel par points pourquoi
la droite ne l'a pas fait avant écoutez
on va attendre d'avoir le détail parce
que là on est encore sur les grandes
généralités certes il ya plus de détails
qu'on en avait il ya quelques mois mais
moi j'attends de voir le détail des
choses parce que le régime précédent
n'était certainement pas parfait si ce
n'est que le régime nouveau il ya
certaines inquiétudes qui ne sont pas
encore complètement levé donc on va
attendre de rentrer dans le détail des
choses et ce que j'espère c'est que le
parlement au mois de février pourra
rentrer dans le détail des choses et
c'est que je crains avec une loi cadre
qui ne va nous faire peut-être voter que
sur de très grands principes on ne
puisse pas les noms des tailles des
choses et notamment dans le détail du
coût des mesures qui ont été annoncées
donc donné nous encore un peu de temps
avant fectivement de nous positionner
très bien il va falloir attendre pour
rentrer dans le concret merci beaucoup
fait d'allier d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
nouvelle réaction première action avec
vous bernard jomier qu'avez vous pensé
du discours du premier ministre
une heure de discours beaucoup de
grandes généralités nous dit philippe
dallier est ce qu'on y voit tout de même
un petit peu plus clair après ce
discours et puis cette séance de
questions d'actualité
un discours très principe ya
effectivement des principes auxquels on
peut souscrire sur l'universalité sur
l'universalité surtout à un certain
nombre de principes et puis après un
brouillard on va dire qu'il commence à
se dissiper un suis tout à fait d'accord
il ya des éléments qui apparaissent mais
qui rendent toujours pas la réforme
lisible et surtout surtout vouloir
changer de système de retraite
donc ce qu'on appelle la réforme
systémique la migration vers un système
par points
et en même temps régler les problèmes d
équilibre des régimes de retraite
c'est incompréhensible et c'est beaucoup
trop complexe et le résultat c'est que
en gros dans le nouveau système
avec ce qu'on sait il n'est pas exclu
que tout le monde soit perdant oui c'est
ce que vous nous dites d'ailleurs et
bien ce se disent qu il a eu pour effet
d'avoir une unité syndicale contre lui
notamment à la cfdt qui a souligné la
ligne rouge en que représentait lâche
pivot à 64 ans effectivement le problème
c'est d'avoir injecté cette partie de
réformes budgétaires dans cette réforme
systémique qu'en pensez-vous jean marc
gabouty mais là je la gelée qui vibre on
va dire à 64 ans que je ne sois pas
forcément même pour tout le monde je
pense totalement carrières longues c'est
pas une c'est un principe c'est pas une
décision
c'est une conséquence du système vers
c'est comme ça quand on équilibre
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de premier
ministre l'a dit le départ l'âge de
départ moyen âge départ moyen il faut
pas confondre avec l équilibre s'il ya
des gens qui vont d'assas d'oise sont
trois ans et demi donc je dirais ça n'a
rien il faut pas se focaliser il faut
pas se focaliser là dessus
moi je trouve le discours du premier
ministre
tel qu'il a été tel qu'il a été présenté
je parle pas des
lire et de sa prestation de devant le
sénat où c'était très très partiel j'ai
écouté tout le discours à midi un petit
peu plus mouillé car je veux dire qu'il
est excellent la seule chose est sûre le
seul problème que je me pose c'est que
je me demande pourquoi il n'a pas été
fait il y à un mois ou deux mois je
pense qu'on aurait des niches la
condition pour entrer dans le détail si
vous les deux mesures très concrètes que
ce soit 70% pour la pension de réversion
la bonification dès le premier enfant au
lieu du troisième
voilà il ya tout un train de mesures
excessivement concrètes extrêmement
précise même si le financement global ne
peut pas être détaillé ses preuves dès à
présent c'est d'ailleurs votre problème
essentiel un qui tiennent la mare de la
question du financement
comment est-ce qu'on va financer par
exemple c'est 1000 euros au minimum de
retraite ou encore est bien la question
est bien de la revalorisation du
traitement des enseignants pour
compenser l'effet du futur système pour
vous certains gros point d'interrogation
exactement parce qu'effectivement sur
les mesures qui ont été détaillées ce
matin il est difficile d'être contre
puisqu'un certain nombre de dispositions
quand même vous dans le bon sens
notamment la revalorisation des
retraites des mères de familles des
personnes qui ont une carrière hachée
pour des accidents de la vie que ce soit
la maladie le chômage donc finalement
assuré quand même à chacun au moment où
il rentrera à la retraite un minimum lui
permettant de vivre décemment je pense
que chaque français ne peut être que
favorable avec ses dispositions
alors comme l'a très bien dit philippe
dallier aujourd'hui l'impasse qui est
devant nous et quand même celle du
financement dans le discours de ce matin
je n'ai entendu qu'une mesure qui vient
ajouter des recettes à savoir
l'augmentation de la cotisation de
solidarité pour les revenus perçus au
delà de 120 mille euros mais je ne suis
pas sûr que cette augmentation alors va
falloir qu'elle soit très très très très
très très forte et espérer que le
salaire moyen des français augmente très
très très significativement pour qu'on
en est là la solution de l'équilibré du
système ne vous n'êtes pas en désaccord
avec le principe de la réforme
ce qui n'est pas le cas de patrick
canapa trey canard qui est au micro
d'alexandre poussins qui lui aussi a
tout à l'heure interpellé et bien
le premier ministre alexandre c'est à
vous oui patrick kanner cette réforme
des retraites va allonger la durée de
travail des français vous n'êtes pas
satisfait non les français vont devoir
choisir travailler plus et gagner moins
donc c'est un choix extrêmement brutal
monsieur le premier ministre parlait de
décisions non brutale s'est
manifestement pas ce qui est en cours
aujourd'hui
moi je regrette cette vision très
budgétaire de ce mode de calcul pour la
retraite
finalement on aurait pu laisser le
système touraine prospérer
tranquillement on n'aurait pas eu toutes
ces manifestations
c'est un système twain c'est
l'allongement l'allongement des
cotisations un trimestre où les trois
ans pour atteindre 43 ans et l'équilibré
général du système de retraites dans
notre pays
donc moi je regrette finalement ce s'est
tenu que cette amnésie vis-à-vis d'un
système qui fonctionnait correctement
aujourd'hui le gouvernement veut aller
vite avec brutalité
manifestement en ayant notre histoire
sur le mode de calcul des retraites dans
notre pays il veut attirer les syndicats
vers lui je crois que c'est raté avec la
cfdt
et quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé
pour l'assurance chômage on peut
s'inquiéter d'une volonté de confier
maintenant aux corps intermédiaires une
forme de responsabilité dans le système
il ya une forme de cynisme aujourd'hui
dans le gouvernement c'est un gage qui
est donnée à la droite
cet âge pivot stage équilibre la droite
d'ailleurs ne sied pas ton prêt a trompé
en applaudissant fortement le premier
ministre d'alors sur le sujet mais ce
que vous reconnaissez qu'il ya quand
même des mesures sociales dans cette
réforme pour les petites retraites pour
les femmes pour les agriculteurs oui en
ne sachant pas comment les calculer
comment les finances permettez moi
l'expression
prenons l'exemple des des enseignants
aujourd'hui avec le nouveau système il
perd de 300-400 parfois 1000 euros par
mois de retraite
on va les augmenter un milliard de
milliards 12 13 milliards annoncés
comment va ton fiancé cela je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ait encore beaucoup
dans l'improvisation avec un système qui
manifestement est combattu par une
majorité de français est ce que vous
craignez un univers social très dur avec
la cfdt qui rentrent vraiment dans dans
le conflit si la cfdt décident ce soir
après son bureau confédéral de rentrer
dans le conflit de manière claire et
nette
bien sûr le climat sera difficile moi je
regrette alors que nous aurons bien
d'autres sujets que sur une question à
caractère budgétaire
eh bien on met la france dans la rue
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup patrick
kanner c'est à gotham merci beaucoup
alexandre jacques zam vous faire bondir
hiver social très dur nous dit patrick
kanner à ce que vous êtes d'accord là
dessus vous qui représentez bien aussi
le parlement des étudiants il ya eu
quelques annonces un quand même qu'ils
étaient plutôt favorables aux étudiants
notamment ceux qui ont un job en même
temps acquise et tu dis oui tout à fait
je pense que les mesures qui sont
annoncées concernant les jeunes prennent
en considération le fait que beaucoup
sont obligés de travailler pendant leurs
études
quand le premier ministre dit un jour
travaillé un jour cotisé égale un droit
à la retraite ouvert je pense que c'est
une bonne chose notamment pour pour
notre génération
si je peux me permettre de réagir à ce
que disait monsieur kader à l'instant
qui dénonce beaucoup de cynisme de la
part du gouvernement
les gens de ma génération on a grandi
moi j'ai 25 ans aujourd'hui on a grandi
avec la question des retraites tous les
cinq ans on nous repose continuellement
la question la question des retraites
vous disiez sur ce plateau tout à
l'heure qu'on a encore besoin de détails
concernant le financement
si je peux me permettre on a quand même
aujourd'hui un discours fondateur sur ce
qui va se passer
ça fait deux ans qu'il ya des
négociations on entendait un peu tout et
n'importe quoi
le premier ministre a même employé
vendredi le terme de fait que nous au
moins aujourd'hui en à ce que j'ai envie
d'appeler un discours de la méthode
comment ça va se passer pourquoi et dans
quel échelon le 22 janvier le premier
ministre va présenter le texte en
conseil des ministres et à partir de là
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat seront
saisis et je pense que en l'occurrence
le projet doit le contenu du texte
seront l'occasion de parler du budget à
titre d'exemple le l'assemblée nationale
est encore en train d'examiner le projet
de loi de finances pour 2020 qui est
parti du sénat la semaine dernière donc
je pense que chaque chose en son temps
aujourd'hui tout à fait aujourd'hui on
lève un voile sur un certain nombre de
sujets et j'entends ce j'entends ceux
qui dénoncent le sionisme est réellement
on a là malgré tout on encourage que
toutes les précédentes majorité n'ont
pas eu donc moi je salue au moins
l'initiative ne commença répond à vos
inquiétudes quand on entend parler de
ces
jeune ces étudiants qui disent je sais
même pas si j'aurai le droit un jour à
la retraite vous dites bombe à la salle
répond en partie à vos inquiétudes alors
premièrement je parle pas au nom des
étudiants n'est pas un syndicat mais en
l'occurrence la question qui se pose
c'est pourra t'on avoir une retraite
ce projet de loi dit oui vous pour en
avoir une sous certaines conditions
ensuite on peut être en désaccord avec
les congolais
je crois que nous jeunes en tout cas on
a conscience d'avoir eu un système
français qui est très généreux si on
veut le conserver c'est sûr qu'il faut
aussi pouvoir faire des efforts et ça je
pense que tout le monde le partage
je le disais tout à l'heure donc c'était
une espèce de véritables marathons
impôts raider philippe entre leur qu'il
a passés entre midi et 13 heures à
parler de cette réforme ensuite a été
largement
interrogé lors de la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement je vous
propose d'écouter la réponse qu'il a eu
à l'interpellation d'eliane assassi la
présidente du groupe communiste qui a
véritablement attaquer le gouvernement
écouter la réponse d'edouard philippe an
la perte de pouvoir d'achat massive des
retraités
actifs mais c'est ce qui se passerait
madame la présidente si nous ne faisons
rien
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
faisons un régime universel un régime
universel dans lequel au fond les
françaises et les français ont les mêmes
droits et c'est madame madame la
présidente
les mêmes droits les mêmes droits quelle
que soit l'activité professionnelle les
mêmes droits les mêmes devoirs
m'enfin ça devrait vous parlez madame la
présidente les mêmes droits les mêmes
devoirs ses seins dans une démocratie
est dans une république
c'est même la promesse initiale la
promesse initiale du régime des
retraites mais vous le savez
parfaitement
c'était ça elle était portée par votre
camp à l'époque par votre parti et
peut-être même qu'on n'aurait pas réussi
à créer ces régimes de retraite s'il n'y
avait pas eu cette promesse initiale et
vous le savez parfaitement et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui certains
l'abandonnent pour préserver peut-être
des situations acquises peut-être des
intérêts maintenant je me avez vous été
convaincu par cette réponse d'edouard
philippe qui n'a cessé de dire que ce
qu'il prévoit finalement c'est conforme
à l'esprit initial du conseil national
de la résistance
universalité initial je précise qu'il
répondait à une question d'el ghanassy
qui disait c'est un bon taux de personne
n'est dupe et pour elle eh bien ça
prépare une retraite qui va vers la
capitalisation mais c'est ce que je
disais sur le plan des principes
évidemment on est d'accord mais ça c'est
un exercice de démocratie parlementaire
ça s'appelle pas autrement parce que la
réalité c'est que non les laits nega
élite elle est dans les professions
celui qui est la profession la plus
pénible
on va lui donner des droits
supplémentaires donc il aura pas les
mêmes droits et heureusement il aura des
droits supplémentaires parce que son
métier est très pénible
le fonctionnaire de police il aura aussi
des droits supplémentaires
donc ça c'est un exercice de démagogie
parlementaire cdu principe yale et ça ne
vaut malheureusement pas grand chose la
réalité vous quand vous rentrez dans le
détail alors on passe au système de
points la valeur du point
le gouvernement nous a dit vous en vous
inquiétez pas ce sera inscrit dans la
loi dalo pourrait bien sympa on sort de
l'examen de la loi de sécurité sociale
qu'est ce qu'elle fait le gouvernement
il a mis des dates charge par la
sécurité sociale en violant la loi
simone veil de 1995 zahia bah oui mais
on peut changer la loi la loi est lé
parlement
une autre toile l'un des faits donc là
maintenant il dit c'est les partenaires
sociaux qui vont garantir mais les
partenaires sociaux c'est pas les fonds
des pouvoirs du gouvernement c'est pas
ça le le le partenariat social
ça n'est pas ça bon donc la conception
du gouvernement la conception générale
les grands mots les beaux principes on
peut les entendre la réalité des actes
c'est que tout est flou et tout peut se
solder par un système qui soit
défavorable pour l'ensemble des français
est ce que vous êtes d'accord jean marc
gabouty ce qu'une loi peut faire une
autre peut le défaire les garanties on
ne les aura pas comme ça sur les
chaussures sont de deux plateaux et des
missions dès qu'on parle réforme c'est
synonyme de peur de méfiance de crainte
etc
bateau dans l'arrêté six mois temps en
temps quand on part réforme ça peut être
aussi synonyme je dirais d'espérance
sans avoir de certitude absolue parce
qu'il ya des choses qui restent
effectivement a précisé je crois que
c'est laid des grands principes de cette
réforme s'inspire effectivement de
grands principes qui ont été mises en
oeuvre dans d'autres époques d'une
certaine forme de gaullisme social c'est
à dire que c'est l'état qui cadrent les
choses et qui on confie ensuite la
gestion aux partenaires sociaux
après tous ses partenaires sociaux qui
râlent par rapport à ce système à points
il gère bien ensemble aujourd'hui les
régimes complémentaires de l'agirc
donc je dire que il ya quand même là une
certaine contradiction dans la position
qu'il que certains prennent et dans ce
qu'ils font tout au long de tout au long
de l'année
moi je crois qu'il y à une avancée
sociale qui me paraît évidente pour tout
un tas de profession pour les carrières
interrompues pour les carrières longues
qui sont pris en compte la pénibilité on
pourrait pas rentrer dans des tailles
mais qui est également plus en compte
les mères de famille je dire que le
minimum à 1000 euros avec un financement
christine lagarde l'a évoqué qui sera
probablement insuffisant dans la partie
qui a été dévoilé sur une surcote au
dessus de 100 à 1000 euros mais ça c'est
quand même pas je dirais le gouvernement
des riches qui l'a inventé vous me
cassez
quote je dirai au dessus de 100 ménagé
ses d'injustice sociale donc soit avoir
un petit peu d'espoir que tout ne soit
pas précis aujourd'hui que tout ne soit
pas parfait bien évidemment mais on
rentre dans une grande réforme qui peut
nous mettre dans un certain équilibre
pendant plusieurs décennies avec un
effort d'équité de justice que tous ceux
qui vont qui va avantage au moins
j'espère ce soir seront un petit peu
plus optimistes que la tendance générale
chrétienne la varde pour revenir tout de
même sur rolle le point que vous pointez
du doigt le risque de baisse de la
valeur du point
c'était votre candidat françois fillon
qui l'avait dit lors de la campagne
présidentielle il avait dit ça a
beaucoup tourné sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment ces derniers temps il avait
dit ce qui est pratique avec le régime
par points
c'est que effectivement on peut agir
plus facilement sur la valeur du point
est effectivement plus facilement
réduire les pensions c'est ce qu'il
avait dit
lors d'un petit d'un petit déjeuner
devant la fondation concorde qu'est ce
que vous en pensez juste déjà je
voudrais revenir sur les propos de
bernard joly je suis assez autour je le
rejoins ont peut-être pas dire que le
système est égalitaire mais en tout cas
il sera équitable enfin en tout cas dans
ce qu on en a entendu ce que ça ne me
choque pas que chacun certains et des
droits entre guillemets valoriser parce
qu'ils ont subi une pénibilité ou un
accident de la vie au moment de leur
carrière donc effectivement on sera pas
tous traités deux exactement de la même
manière non aux monstres à traiter de
manière équivalente en tout cas ce sont
les principes qui ont été exposés alors
après sur le une dévalorisation du point
au cours de
j'ai envie de vous dire je pense que je
reconnaîtrais encore un certain nombre
de réformes des retraites avant
d'arriver à la mienne donc j'essaie
d'être optimiste et de me dire que non
en tout cas de ce que j'ai entendu ce
matin dans la bouche du premier ministre
villepin lui le garant c'était tout
début de son discours il a dit on aura
une retraite qui ne sera pas inférieure
à 85 % du smic pour quelqu'un qui a eu
une carrière complète
oh mon niveau du smic donc aujourd'hui
c'est aujourd'hui c'est me l'a jamais
appliquée demain ça sera ensuite il nous
a bien dit que le point sera indexé non
plus sur l'inflation mais sur les
salaires augmentent plus vite que l'un
supérieur j'ai envie de vous dire
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai envie de le croire on va voir
le classement si on ne le croit pas faim
si si moi je ne le crois pas mais par un
aucun français ne va le croire et on va
être dans une situation de blocage c'est
ce que j'ai toujours dit je ne suis pas
du tout pour combler qu'il soit bloqué
mais qu'ils avancent donc aujourd'hui je
le crois je reste toujours sceptique sur
le financement ce sera certainement
demain après demain
donc on regardera ça au moment où la loi
arrivera devant le parlement mais pour
l'instant faisons confiance
la droite donc plutôt constructive au
sénat ça devrait plaire à martin
lévriers sénateurs la république en
marche il est à votre micro alexandre
pouchard salle des conférences en louis
martin février le gouvernement n'a pas
fait beaucoup de concessions aux
syndicats qui sont très mécontents 1
contre cette réforme des retraites le
conflit social va se durcir vous
craignez un univers social très dur
alors je ne suis pas au milieu des
syndicats donc je ne peux pas vous dire
ça va se durcir ou pas c'est le rôle de
savoir quelle est leur quelle est leur
démarche à partir de maintenant les
choses ont été mises sur la table il ya
très longtemps qu'on parle de ce sujet
tout est mis sur la table enfin vous dit
qu'on n'a pas fait d'effort ou pas de
mesures envers les syndicats on les a
écoutés pendant deux ans on a tenu
compte de d'énormément de
de leurs revendications en particulier
dans le domaine de la solidarité j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure à l'hémicycle et
donc les efforts sont très importants
donc je pense que chacun va trouver
raison ensuite rapidement mais sur
l'allongement de la durée du travail des
français le gouvernement devait rester
droit dans ses bottes
est-ce que c'est droit dans ses bottes
que de dire la vérité est ce que il faut
cacher aux français sans arrêt ou se
mentir et de dire non n'augmentera pas
l'âge de départ à la retraite ou non
n'augmentera pas les cotisations à
partir du moment où la démographie et se
caler on sait bien qu'il va falloir
regarder comment équilibrer le régime
des retraites et qu'une des pistes
étaient celles là ce que propose le
premier ministre est assez simple il ne
fait que reprendre ce qui se fait
finalement aujourd'hui où les gens ne
prennent pas leur retraite à 62 ans mais
quasiment 64 ans déjà donc finalement
l'inflexion que nous mettons n'est juste
quelque part ce ne sont que des mots
mais absolument pas des mesures qui vont
changer la vie des français
la gauche de l'hémicycle du sénat dit
que vous avez donné des gages à la
droite notamment excès tâche
d'équilibrer 64 ans vous qu'est ce que
vous répondez
je réponds c'est faux je réponds que la
gauche l'a déjà fait il ya cinq ans
complètement sauf sur la lune spéciaux
peut-être pour ne pas avoir de grève
dommage et si on regarde toutes les
mesures sociales dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure si je parle des femmes si je
parle des familles si je parle de vue du
minimum pour la vieillesse va j'en ai
comme ça énormément je veux proposer qui
sont des vraies mesures sociales que
personne n'avait jamais fait je pense
aussi à tous les jeunes qui ont un petit
boulot pour payer leurs études qui
aujourd'hui sont payés cotisent mais
n'ont droit à rien pour la retraite tout
ça change donc ce sont là les vraies
mesures solidaire et qui vont dans le
sens de ce qu'on appelle la gauche donc
on appelait on
on annonce plein de mesures sociales
mais on ne sait pas comment va la
finance et c'est la bonne méthode
elles sont clairement annoncée et
comment on va les financer tout
simplement dans le partage d à peu près
14 % de pib qui servent de retraite dont
une partie qui augmente c'est la
solidarité les 25 points de solidarité
aujourd'hui on en dessous des 25 %
on passe à 25% de solidarité un exemple
tous les salaires au delà de 120 mille
euros annuels donc dix mille euros par
mois ou avoir une surcotisation qui leur
donnera droit à rien pour leur retraite
mais qui servirait sera la solidarité en
particulier celle là fabien merci
beaucoup à vous en parler vrille et
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup alexandre on apprend que
matignon vient d'annoncer que eh bien
c'est la génération 80 5900 né en 1985
au niveau des cheminots de la ratp de la
sncf qui sera concernée pour le moment
de la bascule à ce régime universel
votre réaction jade zahab écoutez je
crois que c'est assez transparent le
gouvernement essaie de cette fois ci se
mettre du côté de tous c'est tout c'est
française et tous ces français qui sont
qui subissent un peu les grèves dans les
transports on essaye de je vais oser le
terme acheté la paix sociale en essayant
de dire à aux personnes qui travaillent
à la ratp à la sncf ont fait un geste
vers vous alors pourquoi pas mais
ensuite quand on regarde quand on compte
on élargit un peu le spectre on se rend
compte qu'on commence finalement déjà un
peu à effriter le principe
d'universalité en segmentant en disant à
alan à vous on va vous donner ça à vous
ça et c'est donc je comprends
complètement la logique puisqu'il ya des
français qui ont du mal à aller au
travail tous les jours qu'ils subissent
bon point d'interrogation à voir ce
qu'il y aura dans les textes
oui on lâche du lest à ce vraiment
productif selon vous jean marc gabouty
que pensez vous de cette mesure ça avait
été murmuré mais ne l'avait pas dit à
12h01 tout à l'heure le premier ministre
je la comprends mais je regrette mais ce
sera un motif d' accélération je dirais
des rames sans conducteur dans la ratp
ça c'est clair
c'est clair si voilà il faut qu'ils
réfléchissent mais voilà ils
réfléchissent pas suffisamment ce genre
de choses ça va créer une inéquité du
coup dans le moment où on va passer d'un
régime à l'autre selon qu'on a un régime
spécial aussi long on est au régime
général bernard geniès ça peut créer un
autre front un autre mois notre sujet
compliqué on comprend bien le sens de la
mesure où le gouvernement est pris dans
ses contradictions voilà il est l'assise
de cette réforme de retraites tout ça
était mal mal emmanchée il est mal
partie dans un climat qui n'est pas un
climat de confiance et une réforme aussi
importante que la réforme systémique
vous avez besoin d'apaiser d'écarter les
sujets qui sont des sujets annexes qui
peuvent empoisonner le débat et la
réduction de certaines inégalités
elle est tout à fait en temps dable
entre les régimes et moi je la défends
et ce n'est pas le sujet principal le
sujet principal
c'est 65 millions de français et leur
retraite et réduire les inégalités de
certains régimes
oui bien sûr et ça se fait
progressivement par ailleurs c'est une
spécialité maintenant de ce gouvernement
de légiférer pendant trente ans on l'a
vu sur un autre sujet soit lastic en
2040 c'est ridicule je le dis très
tranquillement ça n'a pas de sens soit
la mesure est nécessaire il faut avoir
du courage politique soit elle n'est pas
nécessaire et on ne traite pas du
désordre inutilement
christine lagarde serait bien cette
génération à 85 votre réaction
le sûr que vise le gouvernement avec
cette mesure
mais moi j'ai le sentiment que ça
fragilise la réforme avant même qu'elle
ait commencé vraiment être débattu ce
qui est aujourd'hui quand même toute une
tranche de personnes ceux qui sont entre
74 et 85 qui sont dans le régime général
qui eux vont se voir appliquer le
nouveau régime et 11 rbds à mon voisin
qui lui est rentré à la ratp où lui
rentré à la sncf on lui rentrer dedans
il va il ne va pas être il va pas être
concernés par la réforme
est ce que c'est normal non alors qu'ils
sont exactement la même année qu'ils
auront la même espérance de vie qui vont
vivre dans la même époque et juste parce
qu'ils n'ont pas choisi la bonne
entreprise le bon métier au moment où
ils sont rentrés sur marché du travail
et je pense que ça voilà c'est une
faille pour qu'une rave enfin pour
qu'une réforme soit acceptable
j'estime fin je pense qu'il faut que
tout le monde se sente concerné en même
temps à la même date
l'objectif 1 vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est effectivement certainement
est bien de vouloir résoudre à la
situation de blocage dans laquelle nous
sommes actuellement d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure et bien le président du groupe
les indépendants claude malhuret
interpellé le gouvernement sur ce sujet
on l'écoutant
monsieur le premier ministre la france
est aujourd'hui divisée en deux
ceux qui râlent et ceux qui râlent
contre ceux qui râlent ces derniers
jours on a surtout entendu les premiers
je voudrais parler des autres de tous
les autres ceux qui ne défilent pas
qu'ils n'ont pas de mégaphones pas de
pancarte parce qu'ils savent qu'un
examen objectif des faits est toujours
trop long vo une banderole ceux qui ne
font pas grève et se font parfois pour
cela injurier ou crever leurs pneus ceux
qui ne supportent plus de voir que
lorsqu'on a un problème avec le
gouvernement
on s'en prend aux travailleurs naufragé
dans des transports à l'arrêt aux enfant
se heurtant à des grilles d'écoles
fermées aux chefs de petites entreprises
je vois que les râleurs ne sont pas
seulement dans la rue
aux chefs de petites entreprises
supportant seul le coût de l'absentéisme
forcé de leurs employés ces français là
sont beaucoup plus nombreux que les
grévistes mais comme ils ne manifestent
pas personne ne se soucie d'eux et il
continue de ramer en attendant un métro
qui ne viendra jamais où un train qui
sera supprimé est il pas temps comme le
proposent certains de nos collègues sur
ses bancs de réfléchir à de nouvelles
dispositions sur le service minimum
garanti
mon style inimitable et illimité de
claude malhuret a d'ailleurs répondu le
premier ministre
on peut aussi rappeler qu'une grève qui
ne dérange pas c'est pas vraiment une
grève et que la grève est aussi un droit
il faut quand même rappeler bernard
jomier où on peut aussi que
manifestement selon toutes les enquêtes
une large majorité de français soutient
le mouvement de grève
voilà et que moi je crois que c'est pas
ça qui est ça c'est un thème récurrent
des mouvements grève
on verra bien mais encore une fois ça
doit pas nous distraire de la question
de fond de la légitimité des principes
de cette réforme des retraites est
clairement il faut que les français
sachent exactement ce à quoi ils peuvent
s'attendre c'est ça qui est important
et ça ça que le gouvernement ne répond
toujours que très partiellement et on
voit sur la dernière annonce que vous
venez de répercuter de matignon que il
ya un ce qu'un climat un peu de panique
ou deux du gouvernement qui n'est pas
serein et qui n'est pas serein parce
qu'il n'a pas poser sereinement les
fondements de cette réforme jean marc
gabouty est la réponse du gouvernement
est elle à la hauteur de la situation de
blocage actuelle tout les doutes toutes
les réformes auger véhicule
la réforme travail des douanes comrie où
j'étais par rapport à porter au sénat
c'était très très très très difficile
beaucoup plus difficile que les
manifestations actuelles est difficile
pour la ministre qui était méritante
j'en connais et que j'apprécie une
personne que j'apprécie beaucoup
donc aujourd'hui on achète
effectivement la paix sociale moi je
crois qu'on l'appelle trop cher mais
voilà donc c'est la jugent tout à fait
d'accord avec avec cécile labarde
ensuite le soutien des français aux
grèves tout ce que ça ne dérange pas
effectivement une certaine empathie
c'est le côté râleur des français comme
le disait claude malhuret ont une
certaine apathie ceux qui sont
directement impactés
quand je crois que le soutien et va pas
durer il va pas durer effectivement très
longtemps contenu des motifs qu'ensuite
on fasse une grève une pression pour
négocier avec le gouvernement et ceux
qui disent non nous on fait ça parce que
vous retirer votre texte et puis on
commencera à discuter discuter de quoi
ainsi mais non donc je crois qu'il faut
que le gouvernement reste sur le sujet
en dehors des problèmes de financement
dont on aura l'occasion de reparler
il faut qu'il reste qui restent fermes
qui ouvre les discussions sur les
modalités sur la partie transition mais
qui n'annoncent pas dès le début alors
qu' il ya eu deux fois moins de
manifestants hier qui fait une
concession à la cgt à la sncf moi je
vois là je n'approuve pas cette
concession je pense qu'il faut des gens
courageux gouvernement restait plus
ferme
jean marc gabouty mécontents donc face à
cette augmentation sur la génération 87
un dernier mot christine navarrenx
urbain ce moment cet hiver sociale
effectivement compliqué et sur lequel
pour l'instant constate que l'opinion
est et reste encore favorable par
rapport au mouvement
ben on pourrait voir le verre à moitié
vide effectivement c'est difficile de se
déplacer après moi j'essaie de voir
plutôt le verre à moitié plein et de me
dire que ma fille il ya eu il ya des
conséquences
finalement positive l'ag défunt la
solidarité entre voisins en tout cas
dans la région parisienne la petite
couronne on est beaucoup plus
accueillant pour récupérer les enfants
des voisins
ensuite les parisiens se sont mis à
faire du sport alors effectivement à
leur corps défendant mais ou tel un
grand pouvoir directement et j'ai pu
constater puisque je faisais prendre mon
vélo pour venir jeudi matin c'était
sapin de noël sur toute la route on
l'avait sorti toutes ces lumières
lundi on avait toutes les couleurs de
punch au alors je dis ça en souriant ça
va pas il faut pas que ça dure trop
longtemps
mais au moins si on aura travaillé à la
coexistence entre les cyclistes les
piétons et les automobilistes ce sera
peut-être de gagner un regard résolument
optimiste de la part de christine la
main pour conclure ce débat marcia tous
les quatre d'avoir participé à ces
dérives des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement tout de suite c'est europe
hebdo avec marie brémaud très bonne
soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]